you
[Applause]
then how we start hey man welcome to fat
man Beyond I'm Kevin Smith
I'm Rahman ah that was close look we're
still behind the bar man
and you of course you could see
everyone's still here so we got a live
audience look at them all socially
distance to the point where you can't
see the audience because they're spread
so far yes socially they're welcome kids
here at the scum and villainy Cantina in
Hollywood on Hollywood Boulevard where
we do the show we were in a Los Angeles
that was open for a minute and then they
have now wisely closed it because the
whole city's on fire wood with kovat yes
not on actual fire no 2020 did you see
the [ __ ] holy [ __ ] there's video it's
so weird to talk about unless we could
throw it up I guess but there's video of
like a what looks like an eagle or
Condor a bird of some sort okay with but
the internet was saying this morning was
a shark but it's not a shark it's a tuna
a giant bird with a giant fish in its
giant claws soaring above a beach I
don't know who [ __ ] like how to luck
to have their cellphone to be like holy
[ __ ] but this giant bird it looks like a
[ __ ] eagle had the big ass long tuna
in its [ __ ] arms in arms claws and
talons thank you thank you we're getting
there I would never have gotten it was
just so pictures I would that's so metal
to challenge ma'am in a minimun the fish
like I watched the video it's only about
15 seconds 20 seconds long but you
you're most of the time you're gone this
[ __ ] fish must be like holy [ __ ]
this is what it's like a fly is coming
this is look at hold in the world and
[ __ ] it's lightning shimmering splendid
it's almost as if like a Disney
character got their wish and they got
[ __ ]
they're like oh no it's a black mirror
deal and then they [ __ ] wind up in the
talons talk of a giant [ __ ] burg at
the very end of the video was haunts me
though I've been thinking about all day
is my four seconds before the video ends
baby this [ __ ] tuna starts violently
thrashing as if to be like let go let go
but what is I know it's a fish what is
this [ __ ] tuna thinking like why
would you want to let go it this bird
was hovering over the beach so he drops
this tuna that's it it's not like I'm
saved
well but to be fair maybe thought he's
gonna catch a heat gust and like coast
out to the water like I didn't see the
water if you just let me go
I'll glide it in maybe that's the
problem cuz you know the fish got one
eye here on one out of there so he saw
the water and he's like we're so close
but really right over budget oh he had
the problem that all Pirates have won't
patch with a word I could've went to
[ __ ] Nick Nick Fury remember that line
at one point and Avengers where it's
like where Tony Stark's like how does he
how does fury see all this and she goes
he turns in any event that horrifying
video somebody wrote under it like off
of course flying sharks 2020 like you
know yeah what else could happen we've
we've seen a lot and we're still here
man and things can't be that bad kids
that's what you got to tell yourselves
if me and Mark are still sitting here
talking about some pop culture nonsense
it could be worse exactly
world's still turning it could be a lot
better we haven't gone feral yet it
hasn't gone [ __ ] road warrior yet the
world is still like in a good enough
place where we could be like hey man
Superman's like toilet paper wars have
not begun yet although if I can stock up
cuz know it's a-comin
somebody's gonna run Bartertown before
this thing is over it is it's it's you
know month
400 of this quarantine of course I've
been dealing with it in various ways
keep them busy and whatnot I've been
doing that show the TBS show you're
making television make it a little bit
of TV from my house man and I realized
oh [ __ ] like because I was like I would
do this all the time if I could do it
the way we're doing it right now where
it's just like tiny unit of people like
me friends and family oh my god that'd
be great but like if you do it as a real
show they'll be like go to a soundstage
build the house and if I could do this
and do that and then it becomes a union
thing yeah which I'm all for unions
don't get me wrong but like at the same
time it's like the fun of this is how
run-and-gun it is it reminds me of
making clerks it's just so like okay
let's try this let's try this very
experimental I realized I didn't have an
experimental period which sounds way
[ __ ] sexier than I meant it but I
never had a film experimental period
it's not like I made a bunch of short
films and then one day I had the courage
to make clerks like I made clerks and
they were like hey welcome in I was like
oh [ __ ] so like you just learn on your
feet
so I find it is like a film school kind
of touch-up you know what do they call
that when you go back to school a
refresher course man because you know on
sets you've got a lot of people looking
out for you in terms of like you know
there's a continuity position on a set
where the person who's continuity like
has a book they follow the whole [ __ ]
script they'll tell you what the eye
lines are the access are if they're like
oh you can't do that that'll cross the
access instant without that position
without like a DP who knows their
[ __ ] eye lines and [ __ ] like suddenly
you have to figure [ __ ] out I had to it
was so like we're shooting the second
one of the short Sun and lockdown is the
name of the little show we make it's on
celebrity show off on TBS we're shooting
the second one
caryl banker is a friend of mine I met
her on Mallrats she was the continuity
person I called it little chair because
she always had a tiny chair tiny chair
club I was like why what's with the tiny
chair and she's like because this job
requires you to get into weird type
places and it just [ __ ] makes more
sense she's so pragmatic and wonderful
and she always wanted to be a
director and she's always the smartest
one on the set but she was in continuity
like she was running book she was
continuity person on x-files for [ __ ]
years and stuff she was on Glee and then
finally someone was like amen
like let her direct and so now she's
like the producing director on Titans oh
wow
she directs a bunch of tight and she's
drags a bunch of stuff Carol banker
amazing friend of mine so anyway we're
making the second short I call up Carol
banker and I'm like banks man I first I
text are you around she said yes I can't
call you she said why cuz like it's not
like I call her all the time
like I haven't last time I spoke to
Carol on the phone maybe two three years
I forget what you were wearing the last
time you brought camera pretty much I
was like girl which way to what was I
work so I called her and I was like hey
man so I'm gonna send you a picture of a
monitor and I'm gonna tell he'll image
on the monitor tell me if like the I the
direction for the characters in the next
shot should be like looking to the left
to right right to left or whatever and
you know I opened with like I am so
sorry to do this I know you're an
accomplished director this is a
continuity question she was like oh boy
let me get my little tiny chair out and
then you know I was like I don't know
which way the island goes she's like
you're adorable send me the picture so I
sent her the picture and she was like oh
it goes this way
she's move it to the ice because I was
like could I would I put the camera on
the other side of the table and you know
she broke it down for me and [ __ ] like
[ __ ] like that is just basic filmmaking
[ __ ] but you take for granted because
there's always some smart people around
you to do that when you're left to your
own devices DIY and stuff you don't have
somebody who couldn't look out for you
in that way and stuff and then what do
you do you have to learn for yourself so
you know Here I am age 49 about to be 50
and I'm still figuring out the access
which is a very important part of
filmmaking for those who don't follow
that whole conversation eyeline is like
here's me and Mark in a two-shot there's
the camera
if we weren't looking in the camera
which you've never do in a movie or TV
shows you always kind of look just this
way or this way and so our eyeline would
be the same
mark would be looking let's look at the
two wires hanging down that's our High
Line so we're looking to camera left
so that way marks looking there and I'm
looking there same mark and I'm not
looking this way and he's looking that
way it's tough so if we were in singles
we would shoot me and it depends if you
got me in a dirty over or something like
that then we're locked in you sounds
again dirtier than it is way sexier than
it--but but if you're just going
coverage of him but then nobody in the
foreground or anything you have to
establish the eyeline let's say you're
having you know me Stan here's the
camera and I'm gonna stand right here
marks eye lines looking at me over here
to the side and step basic don't make it
101 yeah when you do that when you flip
around this word gets complicated the
eye line you can't do the exact same
thing you were doing on the other side
or else the eye line is wrong or else
they're both looking in a direction and
when you cut the shots together it'll
instantly read weird to you because
you're like they're not looking at each
other you'll see this in some movies
every once in a while you could tell
nobody was looking out for the eye line
and stuff and sometimes filmmakers do it
on purpose like Sam s male would do [ __ ]
like that or mr. robot all the time why
because it let this like dissociative
somewhat like illogical feel to it where
you like you know something's wrong you
know something's off but you can't quite
put your finger on it mmm
and something as simple as putting the
eye lines out of sync breaking the 180
rule like suddenly just put you off
kilter a little bit does it kind of
establishes a mood or something like
that I mean like that's I think that's
kind of brilliant good for him but at
the same time don't you think like if
you were the studio the network you're
like hey man these eye lines are [ __ ]
up and they're like what's the point so
put the viewer off their guards the
studio be like I paid for good I love
[ __ ] your artistry and vision they gotta
be looking right right or it's like did
you just [ __ ] this up this is your cover
for we gave you millions of dollars and
that's your excuse it's a choice it's on
purpose i am i was telling mark right
before the show began it's tough for me
to come tonight because i was been
how do I say it I always want to say
Pretty Little Liars but that's not a
little love big little lies on HBO
Pretty Little Liars was a show on
freeform
yeah I think so ABC Family and little
fires everywhere is it showing which I
also watched they're all very they're
not but they sound like like a little
verse so it is I watched the first
season of it and it was good a really
really enjoyable but I was well I
couldn't commit to great there could I
was it was grow good is you know what
it's really fun it was a good time
honestly like there's some [ __ ] I
remember some [ __ ] I didn't because when
we started season two I was like what
happened what is this I don't get what
happened and then my wife is like don't
you remember all this [ __ ]
so whole world like when that show you
know went on HBO when it started airing
like everyone was like ah ain't good
like do you remember there was a general
sense of like it ain't the first one I
mean yeah I think that the first one was
this kind of like sensation know how
they gonna do it again
they shouldn't even try and then they
did and you know everybody's back they
added Meryl Streep and it's it's yeah
more that scat and it didn't scare me
away but I was I got a low priority for
me to watch now I finally got around to
watching it it's [ __ ] dope and you
couldn't break yourself away no to the
point where I was like [ __ ] [ __ ] fat
man beyond I want to fun I want to watch
Meryl Streep act some more and stuff but
can I call into the show yeah I was like
can i zoom in and like you know between
commercials there right there ain't no
commercials on the HBO show like well
fine fair enough all right I guess I'll
go do the show so happy to be here but
would have been happier to keep watching
pretty-pretty fires everywhere big a
little eyes I do had a problem pulling
myself away from something [ __ ] what
have we talked about the windows change
podcast the wind wind of change windows
change podcast if you listen to other
podcasts occasionally less than I ever
used to because I don't have to drive
anywhere anymore
my ears cheat on us as it really is
adorable as a podcaster I never really
listen to other people's podcasts not
because I'm like I'm better than them
but it's just like busy making [ __ ] yeah
I really lose to another podcast like
this podcast which is like you know
couply nerds talker my nerd [ __ ] like I
I get my fill because we do we do that
just true so what is their podcast this
is about what seems to be positive as a
true story
it's a journalist who's investigating
this story that he heard from an ex CIA
operative who also heard the story from
an ex-cia operative that the Scorpion
song wind of change yeah right was
actually not in fact just a heavy-metal
ballad from a bunch of German rock stars
who were in scorpions but was in fact a
CIA Cohen tell operation to help ferment
youth uprising in the Eastern Bloc of
the Soviet Union basically the CIA used
that to win the hearts and minds of the
youth and helped bring about the fall of
the Berlin Wall
that's what the bug is about number one
that sounds fascinating number two it
wasn't scorpions not hoodoo winds of
change does it look that up please
double check who sang when winds of
change scorpions for sure yeah rock me
like a hurricane was their big jam but
wind of change was there like
that's the scorpions I guess I'd rat in
my head
Wow and so like what seems to be so
funny though release your pee I'm like I
don't think you're right Martin let me
let me metal spleen you you know this
white guy I get metal battles mind yeah
hey man hey I however I missed the
Houdini trivia contest we had it's true
before we went on camera which wasn't a
test of any source but if it was [ __ ]
did you fail I know I got a I got a
d-minus I gave you like a 30% lead 33%
lead I was sitting there singing a funky
beat and that was like quick name three
Houdini songs including funky beat so
you spotted me there 33 percent right I
got the freaks come out at night which I
was proud of you for those but I thought
like all right you know we're roughly
the same age he's gonna know he's gonna
rock this have one more and I didn't
have the one more so I got I flunked the
Houdini exam wasn't enough to just tell
him I was just like you can't I said
what are we what are we mark we're not
acquaintances we're friends anyway back
to the [ __ ] podcast so who hosts this
some guy whose name is one person who
tells the one person who's telling the
story he's a journalist who worked for
like New Yorker and had been covering
lots of like sort of government related
operatives and operations you know
especially in the Iraq war and and so
forth but like he heard the story and
was taken by it and like when it sounds
like it's ridiculous that like the CIA
would actually like hire a songwriter
and the songwriter would write CIA
approved lyrics too then somehow
funneled to a band who then somehow make
this the biggest song in the world and
it was in Europe sounds like that movie
about what was it called them the Chuck
Barris movie oh yeah that Clooney
what was it called yeah dangerous
confessions of a dangerous mind it
sounds like a long lines of that
like ridiculous but possibly you know
but then they they start like interview
and I said like clawing at it a little
bit and what seems insane and Daffy
becomes like oh yeah you've seen our go
right like our goes a legit sherry
operation where they cover themselves as
a film crew to help smuggle people out
of a war zone and like they went through
the lengths they hired a producer you
can't just fake your way through this
[ __ ] you gotta actually have to be
making a movie
yes Mel like a film group you gotta
smell like a film crew and so there's a
long history of the US intelligence
operations using pop culture as tools to
execute any number of different kind of
operations no like why couldn't this be
like it's what seems ridiculous on the
surface is absolutely the way they
operate and how deep are you in I'm like
three episodes in and it's fascinating
it's fascinating and it's a hundred
percent of movie like the mini like you
listen to one episode you like oh no I
see exactly what this movie is like I
totally get it
or here's you're like Philip Seymour
Hoffman is like you're crusty sadly the
late Phillips you were hopping but it's
like your crusty career I liked your
movie though I was in good buy a ticket
to that
yeah just like he's basically he's the
the guest what's his face from the Larry
crash from Charlie Wilson's War yes
exactly what picture said guest guest
avocados avocados but like the dude
who's been there seen it all like done
everything it was like well how are we
gonna do this what we need we need a
rock song we need a band and that he
goes and finds the [ __ ] washed up
like singer who had a one-hit in there
like the Peter Frampton of then it's
like you I need I need a song like
what's it got to be it's got to be super
[ __ ] simple it's gonna have a great
hook and it has to have all these little
watchwords of looking for change
wouldn't have changed whatever I mean
demos happen okay we got the song how do
we find the [ __ ] band then you gotta
find the [ __ ] band what are these
guys gonna do they don't want to do a
[ __ ] song written by the say hey well
they can't know it's written by the CIA
they have to know he's written by Peter
[ __ ] Frampton and then like they get
the song they start touring with it in
the last shot of the movie is
they're at the [ __ ] Berlin Wall being
torn down with Tom Brokaw saying we're
saying the end of an era and they just
sort of clap each other on the back and
say you did that and you can't tell a
soul for the rest of your life and walk
off into the [ __ ] night
[ __ ] you give me a ticket to your movie
I want to see it right now that's a good
that is a movie right there it's that
sounds like Charlie Wilson's War two
it's very much like I got an episode get
Aaron Sorkin I want to write it oh right
I mean if I can't then find you can get
the second banana Aaron Sorkin what eggs
but are you okay I am I mean but still
mother's know I'm gonna write this [ __ ]
myself what is the name of it again wind
of change wind have changed which is the
name of the song is the name of the song
I mean I'm not gonna fight you on this
but I do want to just dial back to be
like we're scorpions or a washed-up band
know at that point they were on the top
of the world like they they had had a
couple of hits rock me like a hurricane
I think it'd come out either on the same
album the album before that but yeah
they were the number one touring
European band in the world when they
reached out to them and where did they
reach oh I don't I haven't gotten to the
point yet you're gonna fictionalize it
anyway cuz you're never gonna get to say
on the record so it's it's probably
somebody approaches some dude in the
club and says you know I've got a song
for you and I think we could use another
sample we write to all of our own face
because they're Jeremy it scorpion yeah
really
yeah Klaus - yeah I've got rat in my
head because there's that Geico
commercial we have rats that's good I
gotta get that out of my head go to
scorpions what do the scorpions look
like I would bet at this point they look
a lot like rat white probably white kind
of long hair bald and they were German
there were Germans who sang in English
and without an accent at all like you
couldn't hear it when they sang just in
interviews hello my name is Klaus close
my not and so they were like alright
these guys will [ __ ] these guys
because they can already play all over
Europe
you know they're already kind of in the
European rock scene and that was like we
don't need [ __ ] and striper to do
this Howie how artistically insidious
isn't it this is very cool
there was a spot the third episode this
podcast they start talking about how the
CIA you started a company a shell
company called like the african-american
cultural exchange company and they would
take singers they would take like Nina
Simone and and and Bill Withers and
Stevie Wonder and like let's send you to
Africa because Africa lots of these
countries had been under colonial rule
are now finding their independence and
they could either swing democratic or
they can swing totalitarian right and so
if we show them through the art of
America how awesome democracy is then
maybe they'll come our way but they
never told these artists that they were
working that there was propaganda their
propaganda this yeah and so they would
take these tours and yeah well [ __ ]
go to Senegal we'll go to you know
Nairobi we'll go to you know all of
these places and we'll we'll fly the
flag of America even though it's the 60s
and like America's not that awesome to
us we'll still do this but never would
have been a million years if they knew
there was a CIA front that's nuts man
yeah it's so good so much juice podcasts
HOD Kumar's just discovered them have
you heard that's awesome you heard the
good news
would you reach out to that dude and be
like hey man can I apparently the rights
are being hotly option - yeah it's like
a bidding war now you can see that movie
I mean I could see cuz you just
literally told now I want to see it but
yeah I I can't wait to see that movie I
can't wait to write that movie Hollywood
there it is there's a I wouldn't call it
so much an open plea as a hostile demand
somewhere Aaron Sorkin rolls a tear
can't get higher today if there's a
there's a middle-aged black guy wants to
write it they're not gonna hire me did
you see Aaron Sorkin's movie sold - I
mean the trial of the chicago ate the
net - Netflix
yeah yeah and it was like a fifty six
million dollar
yeah did you see that or is it it was
Will Smith and Antoine Fuqua is that who
this package called emancipation where
Will Smith plays a runaway slave sold to
Apple for 120 million dollars like the
movies not shut yet this is just that
their rights to have the movie so that
says that's not the budget no that's I
mean whether or not that's what they're
committing to it and that was how they
won the package I'm not sure but it's
120 another deal for Will Smith is a
runaway slave I mean they got all the
money they got all the money
Wow yeah that's some where people are
working promising to work yeah Julie
will make this move for you as soon as
we can make a movie we before we I guess
we're getting into the news before we
get into the news let's get into the
[ __ ] news man yeah Marc gathered up
some goddamn news for you I keep staring
at the monitor as opposed to the camera
and I'm a director you know I mean I
just know better I guess that's counter
to what I do though I normally I do look
at the monitor as opposed to the camera
but we should be I should be looking at
the camera I mean you're not looking
down the barrel of the lens that that's
what I want post to do I know on a day
like like when you're doing shows like
this but on a movie said no I apologize
I'm really Bakey tonight like it's
probably coming through but overly
chatty I'm gonna turn it over to mark
down try to shut up it's probably coming
through have really not sure if you can
notice you might have noticed when I was
just like how they goes the scorpion's I
might not I come here tonight because
watching little big liars everywhere I'm
really honest I don't know what I'm this
baked I'm really honest I'm like this
shows not as important to me as Pretty
Little Liars it marks like that's not
the name of the show it is for me right
now
Meryl Streep though bro like it's crazy
how like she just she doesn't even seem
like oh it's Meryl Streep she's every
time she invents a new character I know
that's the point at the job but let's be
honest
let's be honest how many times can you
watch an actor and
that you've seen in many films and
divorce yourself from their entire
catalog right especially with her she's
been you know she's the [ __ ] the
stereotype of best actress because
everybody if you wanted to say she's as
good as you say Meryl Streep she's the
superlative and [ __ ] so you'd imagine by
now after Washington for years I'd be
like I know her trick she's very good at
what she does whatever but still [ __ ]
like I'm watching his show I'm like
Teddy and Meryl Streep even though I
[ __ ] know it's Meryl Streep I'm like
she literally just created she put in
some funny teeth and made a new
character like Kevin discovers acting I
apologize never said sure actress I've
never worked over 26 years but I think I
get it now hold on have you seen this
[ __ ] like she's another person again she
would not fare well in a Kevin Smith
movie I'll tell you right now you could
tell she wants to create a character and
all I wanted to do is like just talk
like all my characters okay can you do
an accent yeah
what's your funniest accent and she's
from Jersey - I think Jersey girl Jersey
pride the father in Jersey she could
have been Jersey girl she was equal to
G's my dear as a girl somewhere my
daughter was who we flew to [ __ ] from
Los Angeles to Jersey so she could be
born in Jersey back when I was like
she'll never be born in California Gazoo
[ __ ] I would never step foot in Los
Angeles and we wound up living here yeah
we she should be the original Jersey
girl of my heart but miles Street is
dreaming this Meryl Streep it's gonna be
huge one day it's gonna win awards and
chill at some point she'll find her
stride yeah and I wondered and this has
nothing to do with nothing obviously
nobody tunes into fat man beyond talk
about Meryl Streep but do you think like
cuz there is four there four other
powerhouse five other powerhouse
actresses and [ __ ] and she's coming into
season two of a thing do you think she's
like just normal like hey man I'm Meryl
Streep so of course I'm gonna do a
hundred percent or do you think she even
ups the game cuz she's like [ __ ] these
youngsters I'm gonna teach I'm gonna
give them I'm gonna run an acting clinic
for them I'm gonna teach Nicole Kidman
how to act I have to imagine there's a
little bit of like
leopold leopoldovich right Jimenez on
ascent carabiner bring you're AGame
everybody first possession she seems
very like personable whenever I see her
on award shows but I guess that's you
know not really the gauge of how real a
person is or anything did you ever read
William Goldman's adventures in the
screen trade book no it's fabulous it's
wonderfully if you're a screenwriter if
you want to know like inside Hollywood
[ __ ] whatever like he's a master
storyteller he wrote Princess Bride the
novel in the movie he wrote in Sunday
I'm in misery he wrote all the president
Mohammed we won't talk about that too
much
yes he's gotta get paid but he has a
story about working on Marathon Man
which he also wrote about rehearsals and
Dustin Hoffman was like you know 28 29
years old like the young lion of the New
York theater that the next generation of
screen acting and he's rehearsing a
scene with Laurence Olivier who is
Lawrence [ __ ] Olivier and there's
describing this rehearsal in which you
know Dustin Hoffman one and he's like I
want to get it on its feet let's let's
[ __ ] go let's listen let's just do it
let's any so it's like marching around
the room and and Laurence Olivier who's
his scene partner is also come on lar
Larry get up let's [ __ ] let's do it's
go sweet like he at this point it's like
80 years old oh yeah it's later in his
life for sure and so like Olivier he's
like trying to get back in the old Nazi
right I'm playing the old Nazi dentist
and so he gets up and he's on his feet
but he's like hobbling and he clearly is
running out of breath and at some point
like you get he said you could tell it
was just Dustin being insecure about
being in a room with Laurence Olivier
and so Dustin wanted to get the
advantage on his side so he got it
became physical it became let me wear
him out until at some point at the end
of it like Laurence Olivier I almost at
Fishburne but whatever same diff same
diff you get it he mix those two up very
easily yeah but he like lets out this
like classic British Royal Shakespeare
Company trained yell my dear boy kind of
thing sort of my dear boy but also like
you know shouting it from the rafters
that are literally shaking because he's
shouting of like weird
with this [ __ ] really yeah he shut
it down he shut it down it's like I get
what you're trying to do and I
understand it and I respect your process
but I'm Laurence Olivier and actually I
have to imagine that kind of calm have
that kind of like you know what dear boy
I don't have to do this [ __ ] anymore so
I wonder if there's that like you know
not to say that Merrill is in any way
diva and not to say that any of the
other actresses were in any way
defensive about her presence right but
there's definitely a power dynamic there
that I'm sure one has to recognize when
you sign on to a Meryl Streep joint well
that's to be George even was your joint
that's the thing it's like I'm sure they
were all like what a coup and we're all
it's like everybody's dream to work with
Meryl Streep every actor or actress but
once the game begins man it's like [ __ ]
it's like being on the ice with Gretzky
mm-hmm
and what a master especially when the
Gretzky just gets traded to your team
and then it's abundantly clear this is
now Gretzky's team it's true oh my god
they're the LA Kings watch that through
this prism when I go home keep bugging
my wife going like all right so that
one's like Robitaille Luc Robitaille and
that one's like anyway it's like that's
Nicole Kidman Kevin know who that is
maybe to you but she's the Luc
Robitaille of my art before we dive into
Anna's apropos nothing but for we're
diving in there's did you ever hear the
Blazing Saddles story about like I just
watched this thing on YouTube
hats off entertainment made it like they
had a video up about a Blazing Saddles
tell of a sitcom know called Black Bart
starring Louis Gossett jr. did they
shoot set thing four seasons of it what
four seasons of it but only one episode
has ever been seen aired once on TV and
then nothing else
they made Warner Brothers this is a
fascinating [ __ ] story they're making
Blazing Saddles it's going well looks
like it's gonna be a hit Mel Brooks puts
in his contract he sees that Warner
Brothers be like oh we're gonna do
Blazing Saddles - and he was like Oh
not without me and maybe never he was
that guy so he goes he puts in a
contract they can't make a Blazing
Saddles too unless they put a Blazing
Saddles sitcom into production and you
know he was like that's never gonna be
possible you could never even now you
couldn't do like unless you weren't a
streamer even if it like but CBS NBC or
ABC you couldn't do Blazing Saddles
without editing it severely and stuff so
Mel Brooks thought like this is a
perfect little [ __ ] you and perfect way
to stop any sequels with or without him
because he's like they're never gonna do
it and they'd you know Blazing Saddles
came out huge success there was no
sitcom so all's well that ends well
three six years later something like
that studio tells Mel Brooks that
they're making Blazing Saddles - and
they're gonna make a series of Blazing
Saddles movies and Mel Brooks is like
I've been waiting for this moment and so
he pulls out his contract and says it's
right there says you guys can't make a
Blazing Saddles sequel unless you put a
Blazing Saddles sitcom into production
and Mel Brooks said they took him into a
viewing booth and showed him three
episodes of a show called black mark
that was a spinoff or just a
continuation of the Blazing Saddles
story and based on the contract based on
the language of the contract it said
that they'd have to produce a series
didn't say they had to air the series so
just to [ __ ] him and keep the rights for
making Blazing Saddles sequels they
secretly made four seasons of a show
called Black Bart only ever airing one
episode the pilot episode what I don't
understand is why you make four seasons
is that what the contrary I guess to
make four that's why I keep going
like you really could have opened up
like one half season about like tada
gonna shut 1-1 it's it's a quadruple
[ __ ] you it's like you know not only did
we make a show to [ __ ] your contract we
made four seasons of it and no one's
ever gonna say [ __ ] crazy
Bob the wisconsin union nine houses for
the starving shows all the but you know
who else worked on it was Steve Landis
Berg who was on Barney Miller he was
like the one guy was always sleeping it
was like what are you talking about
fish like that guy he was on it I guess
he took like Gene Wilder's kind of place
or something like that but let's say
you're on that show I mean you know they
probably didn't shoot it over for years
they probably did it like I take a
hiatus or they just probably did him
back to back to back and [ __ ] cuz after
about year three and you're on that show
wouldn't you be like hey when's this
gonna be on where's my billboard on
sensitive art my mom wants to watch him
Eric premiere party we're on season
three what were the what they like about
season two I feel like somebody
desperately needs to ask Louis Gossett
jr. about this right like he's still at
like hey do you think he was on a set of
watchmen talking to damon lindelof gone
do you know once we made four seasons of
the show
that nobody saw I hope this don't happen
to watch I will have to reach out to
Damon and say did he tell you about this
can you ask him about this fascinating
story Mel Brooks apparently having the
last laugh because they never made a
Blazing Saddles sequel so they spent all
that money making four seasons of a show
- [ __ ] him out of a sequel they didn't
make and that's Hollywood
that's a Mel Brooks is a [ __ ] cow I
remember seeing some story that truck
was his birthday was like three or four
days ago and he's 96 97 maybe and
there's a story about cuz he was a
producer on Elephant Man was a man yes
he brought in David Lynch and his name
wasn't on it anyway for that reason
because his wife's name was on an damn
Bancroft and I think his company's name
was on it but I think he was like I
don't he took his name off I didn't want
people think it was a comedy but there's
a story about how they had a test
screening for Paramount execs and
they saw the movie and it's you know it
begins with a very kind of like
avant-garde very like visually like out
there kind of montage it's establishing
the world and the notes came back from
the executives saying hey we would like
to lose this front half we feel like
it's too confusing and disorienting for
an audience there is impressionistic
film schoolyard II artsy and beautiful
movie and mouths response to this was
listen we are in business together we're
working on a cooperative venture and so
we screened it to you as a courtesy so
that you knew where we were in this
venture in no way should you misconstrue
this screening as an invitation of your
feedback we will deliver you the movie
we contracted to deliver you you don't
actually get a say in what that movie is
oh well hey the best part was the line
he said we don't we don't take advice
from raging primitives he said to his
bosses a [ __ ] that's genius yeah he just
lost his buddy this week sat in the new
liner
well it isn't because it's not really in
our job we should talk a great Carl
Reiner [ __ ] you want to talk about a
life well-lived man he worked for what
five six decades in this business seven
he started unlike sees Sid Caesar show
up shows with Mel Brooks at like
20-something years old and lived to be
98 I believe big beautiful life man like
you'd be lucky to do anything in life
anyone remembers let alone one of the
greatest [ __ ] comedy bits of all time
2000 year old man he's the straight man
in the bit doesn't matter he anchors
that bit so unbelievably well you know
Mel's got the [ __ ] showy part but to
be one half of that man dream come true
kind of [ __ ] like and that was just one
thing he did one thing there was this
great story I got to pull it up
because it was so adorable this guy on
the Twitter told the story about his
father
who was the biggest your show of shows
fan in the world mmm and and his father
like the funniest thing that he and his
father would share was this story that
like Charlton Heston
was a guest on the show hmm and they
were playing some like World War 2 spy
thing and and the joke was he was
supposed to like you know somebody was
supposed to go to this bar in whatever
like Germany and Berlin and ask for a
beef stroganoff and that was supposed to
be the password so that you would get
the papers and so Charlton Heston shows
up as the waiter is that can I take your
order he says yes I'm looking for beef
stroganoff and Charlton Heston says I am
beef stroganoff I can that's the joke
it's silly and slams to do whatever but
he and his brother thought that it was a
funniest thing in the world except that
they could couldn't remember if it was
beef stroganoff or sauerbraten and that
became this like dividing wedge between
his father and his uncle and so fifty
years later you know his father's been
like the biggest like you know Carl
Reiner fan since forever like knew all
of his stuff and do all of this dig
watched every movie call Reiner writes a
book and has a signing in New York and
saw his dad likely what goes up to here
and and waits in line and finally gets
to Carl Reiner says hey mr. Reiner I
just say I wrote you this letter but I
know you're not gonna have a lot of time
I just wanted to know like could you
tell me if it was beef stroganoff or if
it was sauerbraten and it's like young
man I don't remember that was 60 years
ago but thank you very much any signs of
smoking whatever and then like a couple
of months later there's a call that
comes in to his father's house and it's
like it's a it's called whiners on the
phone for you know and and he's like
okay and this is the call but call
Reiner calls back and says yeah I got
you later look really lovely stuff you
wrote and I was very moved by it and I
just happened to be here with Mel Brooks
and Sid Caesar and let's figure it out
and so like I don't know where this
guy's gets a phone call from three of
his like life in Europe watch baby girl
writing and just loved and they meant
everything to him and like call rhinos I
go [ __ ] it let's call this guy and
they're on the phone that's like a half
an hour and it was the best moment of
his dad's life was like that guy just
like out of nowhere decided look at this
dude a call and Rocky's [ __ ] world
that was beautiful
yeah classic I don't know
guys name wars you know what it's like
it's like one of Jesus parables they
didn't have names either and they worked
everyone remembers this Matthew
Rosenberg oh I was actually a comic book
writer now you made it real oh that's a
real story yeah it's a real story comic
writer I'm like hey everybody shut up
happen hold on this is for real this guy
matters alright ladies so maybe some
news we should but but rest in peace
carl reiner yeah it's heartbreaking to
see Rob Reiner's
tweet you know I mean of course 98
nobody complained and [ __ ] what a water
run but you know yeah he had his dad for
[ __ ] all that time for as old as he
is and he's got to be pushing he's
probably in his 70s gotta be right yeah
late 60s early 70s p.m. and there was a
great weird to like we don't know those
people but we know those people and
their family mmm like dynamic or
whatever the [ __ ] are like is a strange
thing like knowing other people's
business yeah like 73 73 73 Reiner is 73
yeah well I mean look from him right now
I'm like I got another 25 year old yeah
Princess Bride to dad had launched
evidence yeah and there was a great I
think I look at the last picture that
that went out for when Carl Reiner
passed away was a shot of him and his
daughter and Mel Brooks
they went to Mel's house for his
birthday man or wearing like
blacklivesmatter t-shirt saying like he
was just he was trying to hang on to see
the results of the 2020 election but
what a bummer when he passed when I read
that I thought of my father cuz he was
like my father loved Carl Reiner made
him laugh and stuff and then so when
you're kid how you learn what is funny
is by older people laughing at [ __ ] you
know like oh that is that's funny I
understand so like he's in my DNA my
comedic DNA a little bit because Moe man
found him funny
I remember making me watch that 2,000
year old man bet when I was too young to
understand it and then later in life
when I was way more into comedy I was
like oh my god
it's masterful word I get it now yeah
all right well rest in peace Carl Reiner
indeed so before we get to the news
proper yeah there was a thing that came
across my desk because I have a desk
that things come across like Marc
himself right across the desk some
people walk in the room and I like Marc
[Laughter]
there they I have it on pretty good
authority yeah that there exists in the
Warner Brothers vault a 170 minute cut
of Batman Forever 171 minute cut all
right so let me do the math how long is
it two and a half hours of Batman
Forever Joel Schumacher's Batman Forever
Joel Schumacher's Batman Forever what
was missing I think that it went much
deeper into his sort of childhood
psychosis and his mental blocks and I
think was a more serious like darker
version of that movie Wow
that you know that was the first one of
the first assemblies that Joel
apparently filed to the studio and they
don't initially cut it down because
they're like it's too dark for kids
remember these come on Batman Returns we
gotta sell these Happy Meals so maybe
let's not invest ourselves in the trauma
of childhood murder right we got Jim
Carrey yeah a stranger's ear man but
said source was like do you think people
would be interested in watching this
version of it like in in a world in
which we are now apparently getting
every version of every movie that's ever
been made yeah I think they would you
know why because the audience is now
sophisticated enough to understand like
you know cut footage back you know
before laserdisc and and DVD perhaps you
know a lot more people were just like
ignorant of it and studios didn't want
to show this stuff you know have people
be like these are mistakes whatever [ __ ]
but now you know we've had so many
behind the scenes so many cut footage
collections on DVDs and laserdisc
every form of media like people are
savvy they completely understand you
could show people a work print and
they'll get it doesn't lose anything
particularly with old [ __ ] it's not like
oh man like [ __ ] effect song done
yeah and also like this is a movie
that's proven itself made a bunch of
money it lived its life and stuff and in
a world where you know Joel Schumacher
just passed away
what an interesting wonderful testimony
that would be to is work you get it to
see a whole different version of Batman
Forever so I think you could totally do
that and people would go for it and get
it nobody would be like why'd you bother
it doesn't cost that much no it's not a
movie that you need to spend you know
tens of millions of dollars to restore
or refurbish you're finished CG on like
it's it's probably you know it will need
to be like color timed and and all that
stuff and maybe a new score needs to be
written for that extra half an hour of
content just cut and paste the rest of
the score reuse queues it's an
impossible task so if it's a thing that
you out there think you might be
interested in not that I am in any way
responsible for with a conduit to but
just an information-gathering tweet
hashtag released the twenty thousand cut
and why twenty thousand you remember why
my god I forgot about that legend I did
go home and tell my wife she's like why
do you care I was like that do the
[ __ ] math I was like good I said look
we have been together for years I think
we have a fairly active sex life you and
I don't [ __ ] that much like that that
that means somebody had to [ __ ] once a
day for 300 and like [ __ ] 40 days
straight oh and she was like you're
right that is a lot leave me as we were
I'll be honest with you made me want to
come back here me like well I'm gonna go
hang out with guys talk about how huge
that number is right but also like
having that much sex with your wife who
you've been with for a while there's no
longer the pursuit and the hunt and the
chase and the courtship and all of that
[ __ ] involved I mean when you're working
on twenty thousand all that shit's
compressed into the one ten minutes how
you doing yeah yeah there's not a lot of
time for romance
I don't believe there is somewhere
thankfully my wife doesn't watch this
show because she'd be going [ __ ] you
mark barnard in' he's very romantic
no she's going cuz you're like yeah [ __ ]
your wife 330 times here who gives a
[ __ ] you know anyone could do that
yeah really teach me how number up a lot
of breathing exercises now pulling a
Schumacher [ __ ] that's commitment to an
art form it really is
so yes released a twenty thousand cut if
you're if it's a thing that you use
twenty thousand written out as a number
letters uh awkward 20,000 Leagues Under
the Sea and they get its numbers
numerical yeah yeah does that does that
pass the walrus yes I was just thinking
if there's another hashtag like
Schumacher uncut or something but twenty
thousand still works because the story
wasn't about how big his dick was yeah a
story was about how much he used it boy
that's number sheared numbers ah him and
Meryl Streep or two modern miracles many
dude you think she's had sex with just
her husband you think so
I'm in a bit married for a long time
yeah but they mean before then I don't
know she's too committed to the craft no
I'm sad she's studying to crash I feel
like we should have somebody ask her
that - Joel Schumacher before he passed
difference of Joel as he volunteered
that information question at a junket
good time on this Mamma Mia three but
before we before I say anything else I
just want to ask you do you know Joel
Schumacher have you heard the Joel
Schumacher sir are you familiar with
Joel Schumacher and or Wilt Chamberlain
look back off Meryl Streep man I know
she's my Jersey girl as I said earlier
she could big little lie her way out of
that question oh [ __ ] well done brother
she's a pretty little liar
yes she's not that's a completely tell
me I'm not wrong though pretty little
liars little fires everywhere big little
lies yeah no it's a bad run you don't
have to be like [ __ ] mm to make a rap
out of it all three of those rhyme you
know obviously I'm not dropping that hot
16 here so I'm not as good as that but
it's the they're all D like Dylan
McDermott Dermot Mulroney all right what
else we got real news
so hey ray Fisher remember that cat
right Oh what do you mean [ __ ] wait let
is this let's let's bury this lead you
want to bury this this should be the
last story okay let's get through the
rest of the news because this was a barn
burner oh it was fun yeah this was this
this rarely happens to the business so
let's save it for life okay it'll be a
delicious let's go through all the
aperitifs it'll be a little a little
ships case of the end totally let's blow
through dessert and then we'll have them
bring us the plant-based filet mignon
did you see I read an article about how
there's a company that figured out a way
this sounds gross but to 3d print a
plant-based steak I mean the [ __ ] looks
and cuts like like the real thing and
tastes pretty good right out of your
Epson what kind of ink do you need two
pairs of 3d steak what a world we live
in that's Jetsons type [ __ ] where they'd
press a button and food would appear
Manas that is some like yeah that's some
Star Trek [ __ ] like I would like an
Earl Grey hot yes boy yeah okay hey next
story
yeah just save that we're coming back
we're coming back to that now that's
that's that's let's face down that's
like the whole car yes did you ever play
the video game Fallout are you familiar
with said video I'm familiar that I've
never played it though it is it's a
long-running sit Atari make it if Atari
2600 didn't make it I probably didn't
play it uh
did not they did not know it's from a
company called Bethesda it's a sort of
post-apocalyptic what happens after a
nuclear war and you know it's a little
road warrior also a little like the
vision of the future from the 40s and
50s I kind of like retro prefab art deco
but what if it had been all nuclear
holocaust a devastation II right and
it's about a guy who's just trying to
survive and figure out you know who he
is and why he is one of the few to
survive and he lost a bunch of time and
it becomes a whole conspiracy thing or
whatever but a game it's a game it's
very plot oriented you know some of the
good ones are yeah I guess so I just
grew up with games or it's like pitfall
where you went from one place to another
I'm gonna jump over this [ __ ] jump over
that [ __ ] baby maybe I'll swing this
time yeah you know what there's a Kong
at the top of this [ __ ] town I mad on
the way up there you know what's coming
you could see it all come barrels so way
is this becoming a movie it's becoming a
TV show from the west-world creators
Julia Nolan and his wife Lisa joy oh
sure our director series order on Amazon
they're gonna spend all the money
because that's all I'm as undoes to
spend all the [ __ ] money which
they'll need to because it's a big world
yeah and it's all based it's in America
so like there's sequences where you're
going to Boston and New York and and
what that would look like in a in a
ravaged sort of nuclear wasteland filled
with like Marauders and all kinds of
[ __ ] but it's it's great there's another
video game that's getting a movie big
movie treatment with what's-his-name you
know the guy that did oh my god Eli Roth
he's doing some big video game animation
as well or adaptation as well and then
there's their game called the rest of us
or the last of the last of us battle and
that's going to HP is going HP yeah do
you remember when like people were like
video game movies they're gonna rock oh
man Super Mario Brothers command but
these new games like sensor story
oriented sound like they could lend
themselves more to yeah and if their
story oriented and I think there's just
there's more and their character
oriented
so you can build you know enough story
attached to those characters it'll make
it a different experience even if you're
following some of the same plot beats in
a way that you couldn't really do with
like Mario and Luigi like what do they
want my what are they look at me I want
to see a whole movie about Qbert and his
needs yeah yeah I mean they keep
threatening to make a halo TV show which
may or may not ever happen but it and
that is another game but what is it
about it's a it's about a sort of Master
Chief is the main character and there's
all like alien invasion plot line and
and vast interstellar battles and [ __ ]
and it's super cool that sounds doable
it's super doable except that again the
main character's story is so it's a
first-person shooter so like there's no
real narrative there about who this
person is and like hard to build a show
around somebody who's not really their
true but yes for stuff like The Last of
Us for stuff like fallout you know
there's definitely a path to making that
[ __ ] pretty good and the west-world
folks you know they know what they're
doing they do when it comes to like a
big done with Westworld
um they're starting this there must be
right I don't know I don't know I don't
know if HBO's announced that they're
making another season or not and I never
finished watching this current third
season did you right yeah did you ever
dig it I never went to - I finished with
one and I was like that was good I'm
satisfied no I just never I remember
when to started I was preoccupied doing
something else than all sudden people
were like well get three it's quasi
futuristic is like [ __ ] season three
what happens season two well at this
rate you'll get around to it you know
next year I know that I'm watching a big
little ice finer to have big little
fires everywhere
I'll probably get to that it's it's
waiting for you on the HBO max I watch
okay anytime you want it I'll be there
I'll be there of the things that I did
not expect to see in the same headline
this week yeah Jason Momoa so I can
Frosty the Snowman we're not two things
that I expected to see I saw a tweet
about this and I honestly thought it was
connected to the first story we were
gonna do because I thought it was had
something to do with very Fisher's tweet
or something like that couple of the
names
crossover and that's what it was the
producer John Berg or something he was
the guy that was at Warner Brothers
that's called out and Ray Fischer's
tweet that's Geoff Johns Geoff Johns is
involved with the frosty movie okay um I
mean look I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] on
anything like go go nuts and if you're
gonna get somebody to play frosty why
not [ __ ] Jason Momoa frosty should be
very enthusiastic to be frozen and I
would just like him to just MAME it
sounds a little bit like Jack Frost
right like didn't we see this what kind
of to some degree snowball who's making
it Warner Brothers is making it I
believe I think it was the other paper
over there I'm a [ __ ] I put another
card in the whole card yeah Warner
Brothers and Stampede ventures take
Warner Brothers studio that made four
seasons of Blazing Saddles been off but
nobody ever saw I had to get to the
bottom of that it reminds me so much of
because it's happened a bunch of times
when Roger Corman made a Fantastic Four
movie that it was never going to
distribute simply to keep the rights to
it yeah
and there was a I want to say it was
Wheel of Time or or some Ringworld kind
of thing but there was a pilot for a TV
show that aired on FX at two o'clock in
the morning in that count and that
counted it was like we shot it we aired
it we've fulfilled our contractual
obligations so now it's still ours for
another however many years it's gotta
hurt
ya know every person who sold the thing
to them they must be like oh yeah it got
me Mel Brooks to me dick Brooks to
Brooks but yeah so Jason Momoa written
by David Birnbaum who worked on elf
he was one of the screenwriters of elf
all right so there you go if you're
gonna make a Christmas movie go for the
guy that made the Christmas movie that
stood the test of time people love that
[ __ ] elf movie it is one of these
what's not to love it's a door yeah but
it's one of the few sort of like modern
holiday fables that yeah it is achieved
Christmas modern day Christmas classic
yeah and by the way the road to Iron Man
mm-hmm yeah that plus is a thorough
equals Ironman that Jon Favreau he's
very talented and I it's so hard because
you can't there's no way to know when
you're making a movie like that oh no
this is gonna be the one that people
will go back to every [ __ ] year look
who you're talking to I mean I mean I
didn't make a holiday classic what are
you talking mr. Mallrats
like you know these cats when they made
that movie elf they were just like ah
they were happy when it came out because
it did all the business in the moment
but I doubt they felt it would have legs
yeah and yet it is like right up there
with Christmas story at this point
yeah and trying to figure out what that
formula is like I think about that a lot
not that I think about Christmas songs
all that much but it's like every
Christmas song sounds basically the same
it's some like kind of jumpy ballad with
bells in the background and there are
three Christmas so what separates every
new one from all I want for Christmas is
you buy Mariah Carey which is like the
last great indelible Christmas song like
how you have the audience decides what
is gonna be the one we go back to how
the audience decides that I want elf and
not rise of the guardians my new jam you
know like they're both good holiday
movies they're both strong holiday
movies but one is gonna be on TBS for
the end of time and the other is like
hey cool it's not HBO because the
difference maker is Will Ferrell
apparently maybe maybe also it's a cool
story alpha was a cute story I mean it's
like splash like elf worked the same way
splash worked and in fact elf
very similar to splash when you think
about it a shot of water
yeah that's what we should be doing
that's what your [ __ ] Cinderella
thing was gave away for free we could
add our own [ __ ] Christmas classic
god dammit not too late
gasp true life is long live as long as
his memory okay well we can we could
come up with something right now a very
a COBIT Christmas everybody just by
zooming it zoom Christmas singing carols
buy a zoom I mean there's the version of
that that goes straight to like the
Hallmark Channel and then there's a
version of that that will be played
forever and ever and ever
that's true depends it depends on what
kind of tech you got going on you know
like some movies are kind of dated by
the
Tech or lack thereof and stuff I'm sorry
I got hung up on the hallmark movie
thing I said when suddenly I want to
fight a fancy girl I was like what I'd
like to make one of them hallmark movies
seems kind of easy they make a lot of
they knew that and I'm not putting it
down by saying it seems easy but they're
very like you know [ __ ] sentimental
nostalgic and [ __ ] and you know they're
they are fun to do it just to try see if
you could pull that off I mean remember
when speaking of Will Ferrell when he
made like a lifetime like murder mystery
man yeah he was like you know what [ __ ]
it I want to try this one see if I can
do it gonna do it like there's a formula
to it and if you hit these beats the
audience will show up and if you can
bring anything else to it and still
satisfy those desires then it's a
[ __ ] hit the son in lockdown thing
for me it was just like oh I like I've
been watching sitcoms my whole life I
don't even have to do 22 minutes eyes up
to do five minutes that's it I think I
could do that
like there's something to be said for a
formula yeah you tell us 75 minute
romance that's set in a small town where
there's a big-city person and a little
town person they both come together and
they have to celebrate a holiday word I
don't know maybe there's a sick kid or a
sick mom and or a reindeer who's lost
and like yeah I was gonna say you need
some sort of fantastical element right
you know and if we're the big city small
town could be I'm from the North Pole
and my dad is Santa Claus I think
they've done that a few times doesn't
matter
do it again our target I yeah no no we
should look into that be fun to go pitch
one at the very least right collect
pitch a hallmark movie and haven't be
like you guys serious like now totally
for real now it's a romance about an
angel and a demon who are falling in
love and wonder if we could sell that
because I would totally legit make that
movie like a for-real romantic comedy
between an angel and a demon setting
like hills Crossing Texas or some [ __ ]
like that
who couldn't do that gotta be
Connecticut Connect seems like all those
movies are set in Connecticut did you
see there was a new story I don't know
why I'm like mr. digression also and I'm
not baked at all
about this this there's two people were
killed in
murder kill river and it's like who's
naming a murder killer let's talk about
this name for a second that's where you
says your romantic comedy like on the
shores of Myrtle kill River that's true
people find love used to be called [ __ ]
kill and that apparently was not cool
and so they changed it to murder kill oh
my god [ __ ] me yeah cuz American man
it's so crazy that they're like I mean
well first off let's not even touch why
it was called pork hill in the first
place but like so weird that they're
like we got to get rid of that that
sounds bad
what else can we call it murder kill
alright I think a live with that this is
to my favorite thing murder and killing
man I tell you this podcast it's too
close to Batman we got to change the
name murder kill I get a seasoned assist
from the [ __ ] murder kill yes oh no
that's [ __ ] marry kill we can put a new
game out called [ __ ] murder kill or it's
just like you only get to pick one
person and the other two people also
like here are your options murder death
kill okay like wait well death could be
gentle yeah slow death like oh no do I
die of old age slowly yeah oh yeah but
in that if somebody offers you murder
kill death choose death because it could
like that's murder is very yeah it's
awesome
it also specific but death it's coming
for all of us I know so you could play
that card you could be like the tuna
that's trying to bring the ladder but
talons of the [ __ ] eagle at the last
minute it makes no sense but you're like
this might work I got this icy water or
maybe he was just like maybe I could fly
I've never been up this high before come
I can't look him what it was when are
you [ __ ] like can't hurt now he's God
ah you got these little wings he's got
the big wing to an eye in the sky all
right yes
more news yeah let's do there's gonna be
where you a teenage be Ninja Turtles fan
yeah yeah yes but not like ardent but
like I'm just by the comics when they
first came I had the I had these been
layered black and white at one point one
of them they were expensive [ __ ]
books those are big wall books and stuff
now watch some of the cartoon and
although I was like way older at that
point but the toys were I was already
grown up in the toy 7 but I've not in
but respect for the for the turtles I
always loved the fact that their origin
is deeply tied to Daredevils origin all
of it is like daredevil country they
were big fans of Frank Miller's
daredevil run and so Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles origin the who's you know
[ __ ] that that turned them into the
Turtles was the radioactive isotope that
blinded Matt Murdock that falls down the
sewer so I was always like that's so
[ __ ] metal and you sit in a hand it
was the foot was the foot plan and it's
just so strange like Marvel never went
after him or anything like I guess the
Volt ultimately when they did the
cartoon they altered enough where
obviously you couldn't tie it to
daredevil but and even when they did the
black and white they weren't like
daredevil but it was just mm-hmm
they were fans yeah who would like I
will reference the thing we love and
they became richer oh yes and everyone
involved with daredevil ever second
right so Daredevils mentor was stick and
so ours is gonna be splinter it's yes
that's why we work so hard all we need
to do is go find something we like
change the names make them Turtles and
rats and we're all good this is an
elf-like formula we have to crack its
space boys babies Mel Brooks basically
it's like hey you know what sure you
could be a barf and not Chewbacca and
you could be all comes back yo Mel Mel
Brooks doesn't yes the cinematic Mad
Magazine of our youth oh my god he was
remember seeing history of the world
part one good to be the king
so funny jump scream come on jump screen
what do we got
so yes team has been into Turtles yeah
Oh Seth Rogen is in throw is Evan as
well don't do everything together don't
you indeed yes Evan are involved they
are producing not writing or anything
they're not writing they have let's see
who Jeff Roe who did gravity falls is
directing and Brendan O'Brien who did
neighbors sorority rising Mike and Dave
need wedding dates he's going to write
the screenplay and it's full CG
paramount is heating up their
Nickelodeon animation and they're doing
it for them and yeah [ __ ] it like more
turtles more honor heroes in a
half-shell look we like you and I will
be on our death beds and there'll be
another incarnation of the Turtles
coming like they're never gonna let that
die cuz boy oh boy what a cash cow it
was at one point and obviously every
time they do it somebody makes some loot
from it because they keep [ __ ] telling
this story yeah I don't know I don't
know what the demographics are 40 mm me
neither me neither because it's gotta be
little kids I mean you'd think but like
maybe it's one of those like
generationally renewing things where
like if they put out a thing every
generation like oh yes green [ __ ]
ninjas how is that not a thing that I'm
down for it's true they eat pizza [ __ ]
yet I do like that they're just edgy
enough for a child you know saying your
prayers a parent you're like all right
then play with weapons and they fight
crime and they eat pizza and they listen
to their [ __ ] boss splinter or
whatever or a splinter you know these
are good morals for my kid yeah and it's
also like it's three teenagers kind of
bristling against Authority yeah those
that you know splinter knows what's
right and you know [ __ ] Leonardo's
not sure if he can be the leader and
Donnie's the rebel and it makes sense it
sounds like you watched a lot more than
I ever did Leo's the heartthrob the so
there'll be more turtles yes
turtles feature-film Sanji Gotham tour
coming soon no you can't you can't stop
that's on April O'Neill and then Casey
Jones returned
like horrible action do you have a
Jarvis good lord well because if you're
gonna have Siri and you can customize
her voice why would you not make her
plug-in sexy British you know virtual
assistant very true why did she come to
life and start a talk I think maybe I
like Mark and wind up your show it's
time to come home
the internet is tired
Siri just decided she want to be part of
the show I was a Maximum Overdrive
moment now oh [ __ ] my watch is gonna
steal my hand and we're gonna see the
big truck of the green Goblin's face on
it yeah we best part of that movie more
Beavis and Butthead is coming Mike judge
just saw that for a two season deal oh
I'm game for that I mean I guess it's
going to Comedy Central
yes so it's not gonna be them watching
videos going huh probably not since
there are no more videos right so it
sounds like you'll be actually doing
adventures probably more like the movie
I think so you know it's it's I'm all
for it I met that guy Mike judge 23
years ago and I still remain impressed
by his character you've never seen him
since man but I liked him so much and he
was so like aw shucks you know
considering he was the guy that did
[ __ ] beavis and butthead he was real
sweet dude yeah it seems as if he he he
made the version of Hollywood that he
wanted it to be you know it's like you
know what this will be the way I do it
I'm gonna make beavis and butt-head for
a bunch of years and they came that hill
for a bunch of years I'm gonna go off
into Silicon Valley for a bunch of years
hmm and then like surround myself with
people that I like who seem to be cool
and aren't [ __ ] with the rare
exceptions
you know there's every now and again a
bad Apple gets in a bunch but he never
seemed he was a little bit slow cos that
way when he's an Austin cat and so I
think that a lot of that stuff was based
in Austin or on his I God I'm gonna
bring the work to where I live and and
these are gonna be my values and here's
I'm gonna make some [ __ ] and why do I
have it be shitty just mark very smart
guy large paw fryer coffee
it's my hack Hill it's very cool thank
you
yeah that boy right no that boy right
Margot Robbie has signed on to be a
pirate of the Caribbean watch can't be
Harley Quinn and a pirate of the
Caribbean can't be two things surely she
can't
she has Jesus that's not the good idea
it took a Hollywood a long time to come
to the idea of an all-female pirate
movie it it would seem to make a ton of
sense you know this Disney doing it this
is Disney doing it and it is a Pirates
of the Caribbean higher to the Caribbean
movie it's not I think it's a spinoff of
the mainline pirates movies because
apparently now there's a pirate verse
right because everything needs a verse
but so they've known about Jack Jack
Sparrow Jack Sparrow is probably a
character in the world if not going to
be a character in the drama gotcha
but yeah and like Christina Hudson who
wrote bumblebee is right in the script
they don't have a director yet but that
bumblebee trailer made me cry it's I
haven't watched the movie because I
don't want it to like not live up to the
trailer but it sounds like it worked
ya know it's a solid movie and yeah
there's tons of like awesome there have
to be tons of awesome female pirate
stories out there they're like why
couldn't you tell that [ __ ] story all
real ones - yeah and to be fair like the
original trilogy or hepatology ever many
pirates they mean right the first three
are about Elizabeth Swann she's
ultimately the main character I wearing
a corset yeah every TV spot pretty much
and she gives the big [ __ ] like you
know victory speech at the end of the
third movie to kick her into the third
gear where she you know he who bleeds
with today with me shall be my brother
blah blah blah blah blah so yeah like
they remember a lot about them pirates
movies the first one's really good it is
really it was a legit good movie I
remember less about the other ones the
second one I kind of liked the third one
remember when they remember they were
making it everyone was like [ __ ] this
ain't gonna work
once [ __ ] Pirates the Haunted Mansion
movie didn't work cuz I'm gonna work and
then it [ __ ] worked like crazy yeah
remember when Dark Horse used to publish
predator comics and I do that was their
[ __ ] bread
it was and those aliens books those were
wall books way back in the day man I had
them and they were part of my collection
when I saw my collection make clerks so
yeah I remember Dark Horse that was
there when you thought of aliens you
thought a dark horse when you thought a
predator you thought a dark horse when
you Dugger aliens vs. predator I think
that might have done it in Dark Horse
first I think they did before it was an
actual movie and so whenever alien or
predator would crossover with Batman or
whatever that's with Dark Horse you're
about to tell me that the world has
changed the world has changed in in a
predictable way we know why don't we we
do indeed now well I mean Disney bought
Fox and with Fox comes the licenses for
aliens and predator and and rather than
renew a Dark Horse they're like no I'll
just take a Marvel thank you now we have
our own version of that that's they are
circling the wagons as they say where
they are you know the one that surprises
me that hasn't happened yet
Indiana Jones what do you mean there are
no Indiana Jones comics there used to be
Marvel published them back in the day
that's true they're like that's that
would seem to be a thing that if Marvel
decided they wanted to publish they
could sell it's just crazy man they're
like no we own this we're good yeah
nobody else needs to do this anymore we
got this what do the vault and or we'll
make it through our own [ __ ] comic
book company we have our own comic book
company now yeah so now that means you
have a chance at seeing like you know
what can iron man versus aliens
iron man versus the Avengers yeah that'd
be fun like you know read the [ __ ] yeah
that's good The Avengers taking on a
Viking ship full of predators
I'd be dope they'd be crazy dope so you
do that Marvel now that you can you
rhythm yeah make that happen
there may be a Scott Pilgrim
animated show yeah there was an
interview in Entertainment Weekly when
they were talking about you know
potential sequel yeah and everybody
pretty was 10 year anniversary of the
release of Scott Pilgrim and so reunions
are the coin of the realm these days in
entertainment journalism seems that
that the yeah and Josh GAD has cornered
the market indeed on those totally there
was very heartwarming let's get the gang
back we had all the [ __ ] lower the
rings in a zoom we got all the back to
the future on the zoom I think they're
doing it all the kindness of their heart
so you think money's being thrown around
there I heard that people are being paid
you know it it was no crime whatever
crime it what it's always presented as
hey this just happened yeah I call these
guys up on the Internet go figure what
else was I gonna do these are
well-organized cameras in these
[ __ ] houses yeah like
somebody's paying for that
yeah not just like you know somebody
zoom bombing in know there's a plan and
god bless him but you know because hey
like lighting a service little truth in
advertising be nice but you know what we
all love fantasy as well yes but but
Edgar Wright was talking about how like
yeah you know there's been conversations
about doing an animated series and they
should the books that they're based on
or lend themselves to cartoon those very
clean and clear style and there's seven
of those books if not more I think
they're seven maybe eight
yeah just why is the no brainer my bet
it'll exist on Netflix within six months
seems like an easy cheap thing to do and
you want to talk about coin of the realm
right now animation is coin of the realm
because you could do it even though
everybody shut down you could still keep
working on animation record voices
remotely [ __ ] like that I mean if I
remember correctly Scott Pilgrim is a
universal movie thank you right and you
know I just remember they had the side
of the they had that whole hotel you
know that's right black Hall H Marriott
or whatever it is like the whole side of
the building then the movie came out and
didn't do that well any movie that has
had that whole side of that building has
not done well yeah I remember being at a
venue at the time and
it used to be financially I should say
people of Scott they loved that movie
but it had been like there's a giant
movie that's making its big debut big
splashy debut at Comic Con and like
we're wrapping a hotel and up until that
point there hadn't been a big comic-con
sort of air ball right there hadn't been
a big miss and then Scott Pilgrim like
they spent all the money they brought
the whole cast they wrapped a hotel that
crosses the whole shebang and then the
movie came out and like it did fine for
something you wouldn't have to did fine
for an indie movie it made something
like 2025 million dollars in a
theatrical run did very well on video
cost a little more than make but it did
very well like it was the huh so it
seems that like even bringing a thing
that seems like it was the the the echo
chamber effect of comic-con at comic-con
everyone was like ah and it was the
first time that we you know especially
these journalists and even its fans were
like well maybe the things that like you
know there's a there's the Comic Con
effect that within that ecosystem
everybody loves it but only that
ecosystem seems to want it it happens at
Sundance having since Sunday the
Sundance effect like they blame it on
the altitude like what time of day did
you premiere what time and the festival
did you premiere like everybody's has
you and if their company hasn't bought
anything yet
like we gotta buy something really yeah
so but I mean it's a universal movie
peacock is launching in like three weeks
they need a [ __ ] ton of content I don't
know how much animation they're planning
on doing but if you wanted to do a big
[ __ ] splashy cartoon like that makes
you want to open with a button or bring
a bunch of people to your platform maybe
weren't there pilgrim is it I saw Sony
too just said that like we're getting
into the r-rated animation business yeah
yeah makes sense why not [ __ ] do it
and again and one of the reasons cited
was we can keep we can keep production
going even with the whole world locked
down yeah and like if you do it right
like in there are the animation houses
and models that don't cause and like
Pixar money more like sausage party
money right well I give you maybe this
for 15 20 million dollars then like yeah
why wouldn't you try an already
might go for it but yeah last story
before the government go back for a big
story is did you realize that Marlon
Wayans was paid $100,000 to play Robin
in a Batman movie that was never made
yeah I remember he was part of Batman
for a while like I remember the story
back in 89 or 88 89 when they made the
movie was they were going to introduce
Robin in the first Batman in Tim
Burton's Batman and ultimately did not
and I remember when they announced the
casting of marlon wayans of course there
was no internet but it did make noise
beyond the internet that didn't exist
with people being like but he's not why
how could he be an acrobat now yes makes
no sense Robin black people can't fly
off trap 'yes' have you met a black
person they don't do that at all you
know so it was just like it's not real
we don't have to be authentic here
because it's not that boy's parents
didn't die so he was gonna be in it and
I always thought it was good that they
left any Robin out whatsoever you know
movies called Batman you don't have to
cram everything in there and stuff but
he got suited up like they measured him
there was a costume and then they let
him know while they were making Batman
like oh it's probably not gonna happen
and so then he was supposed to be in the
next one or something and that's when he
got paid because they were like we're
not gonna do it or was it the first one
it was actually supposed to be the third
one because Tim Burton was going to make
a third Batman so and so we got hired
during returns to be the bat that Robin
then we get introduced in the third one
and they were gonna have a whole like to
face with Billy Dee was gonna like
complete his sort of Hill comes his
trilogy is gonna play Harvey Dent they
were gonna bring Selina Kyle back and
I'm gonna introduce Michelle Pfeiffer
was gonna come back and we're gonna
introduce Robin but then Tim Burton I
think there was like static between
Warner Brothers and Tim Burton because
again after ratchet returns like guys we
gotta sell toys on this [ __ ] they were
like this shit's dark this is like
darkened like not cause the movie opened
Tim boy's parents died
like yeah well yeah we know so he
becomes a penguin and then one boy's
parents throw them into a sewer you know
like this is did you you're doing Batman
Returns right yeah where's the Batman of
attorney no it's more like Oswald rising
I had to put a finer point on it when
Batman Returns he returns to the misery
of a world without his parents like we
got to deal with McDonald's Tim yeah so
he got paid well I'm sure that you know
there was a pair play deal in his
contract which is we hired they did a
thing we paid you money to keep you on a
retainer if you're not in it
that's not your fault that's our fault
and so we pay and apparently he still
gets residuals for a movie that he was
never in which is weird talk about like
when it happened I'm sure he was like
she could have been robbing him bad yeah
but he's had a massive [ __ ] career
he's doing really well so it's like on
the cherry on top of it all is like I
still get paid for the movie they left
me out of totally and I can still say
like his pictures of me in a round robin
suit you think he's got him
if he had to me would have shared it by
now I doubt he Azzam cuz why wouldn't a
guy like that he's so [ __ ] famous
it's not like Warner Brothers would be
like we're coming after you man like
it'd get totally get away with sharing
that hey if anyone knows Marlon Wayans
and if anyone knows if he's got a
picture of himself in the Robin outfit
can you please let him know that we all
would love to see it and not even like
make fun of it we just wanted like
[ __ ] see if I doubt he has that
picture you know who does somebody
somebody somebody had to take a picture
to show some Warner Brothers exec so
that photo exists on there there I'd
love to see what their idea of a Robin
outfit was there are many reasons that I
missed the late great John snip but not
least of which is that that gig found
that picture yeah no doubt you'd have
been like yeah he was planning a series
of those films that was just like the
Superman measures we went yeah looking
for like the story of what happened yeah
and again he also would have I'm sure
found the three episodes that one can
get their hands on a Black Bart one of
them the first one up the pilot episode
is on the blazing set
the Blazing Saddles DVD is it and that's
the only one you can watch and you could
see Lou Gossett jr. I wonder if there's
only Lou Gossett there's only Lou
Gossett because his father wasn't born
yet I guess when did he decide to have a
junior so late in his career maybe
because he wanted distance himself from
that Blazing Saddles
sitcom look that nobody saw but I can't
that wasn't me that was a Lou Gossett
I'm Lou Gossett jr. yeah and one tiny
little story that I don't have very much
information on because I just saw it
before we got in here okay is that for
Jurassic world 3 for which they are
returning to production I want to say in
like July with this month later this
month in overseas is the plot about
[ __ ] Cova because dinosaurs don't
scare me anymore yeah dinosaurs deal
with it they don't worry the dinosaurs
get kovat they just watch the dinosaurs
drop in like so that's what happened
credits it's trying to build masks for
dynasty they're bringing everybody back
- they got Sammy or Dern and Jeff Gould
and Jeff Goldblum that's the news who
they're all coming back what didn't we
know this really I didn't know this
I thought we knew this like I thought I
knew I thought I knew at least two of
them if not all I thought everybody knew
this for a while but everybody coming
back everybody's coming back cuz this is
because they'll be done after this mark
they're never making it no more of these
Jurassic movies time it's personal
I bet you here I bet you the only reason
they haven't shot it is because the
entire cast was probably I'm one of Josh
GAD Reunion [ __ ] silliness and they're
like can you come film the movie please
no I support this a thousand percent
who's doing it the same guy Colin
Trevorrow good for him I like the
[ __ ] Jurassic yeah like the first
erratic world a lot but one of the best
times I had in the theatre that year was
watching that movie like I was like it's
back holy [ __ ] they found a way to
[ __ ] shake it up and stuff I don't
remember much the second one except but
wouldn't a lady carried off or was that
in the first one the first one was a
publicist lady gets carried up yeah well
happen the second one she stopped
running around in heels I remember
everyone bitched about yeah she put on
flats yeah and then some come yeah some
company comes in it steals all the
dinosaurs then auctions in LA
as you can underground like dinosaur and
also had one of the most haunting
[ __ ] images in any of those Jurassic
movies if not in any movie at all when
they're getting off the island and that
one lone dinosaur I'll bet it's gonna
[ __ ] yeah it's sad like you know
[ __ ] the way like yeah crippled kids
are sad but what are you gonna do
[ __ ] it was heartbreaking like I
literally kept rewinding and watching
that [ __ ] moment was like oh and then
they kept going on with the movie I'm
like [ __ ] the rest of the movie what
happened to that guy you just see the
dead holy [ __ ] somebody help him I
remember when uh when Blair Witch
Project was going to Sundance friend of
mine John Pierson was the producers are
up on clerks he was working with that
movie as well so he had sent me the VHS
of the movie before they went to the
festival I hadn't gotten around to
watching it but I knew what it was John
was like this is a fake documentary but
they're playing it very real and stuff
and the fur you know the first found
footage movie that created a whole
movement that they're still working off
of today so we're at the we're living in
Oceanport like I've been with Jennifer
like tops three four months at this
point maybe maybe six months and I don't
know if she's even pregnant with Harley
at this point ER if Harley was born I
can't remember specifically but know it
was 99 so Harley wasn't born Jen was
pregnant because it was around the same
time Dogma came out around the same time
so you know I was like hey they're
talking about this movie at Sundance
getting a lot of buzz and we got a copy
of it my friend gave me a copy you want
to watch it and then she was like yeah
what is it I was like Blair Witch
Project and say all right and so we
watched the movie in bed and I fell
asleep watching it because not because
it's bad I was just tired and [ __ ] she
didn't know what it was she didn't know
it was a mockumentary or wasn't [ __ ]
found footage film she didn't know it
was a fictional film so [ __ ] I'll
never forget her shaking me violently to
wake me up at the toward the end when
the [ __ ] mic is facing the wall
that's like oh my god all that [ __ ]
she was just like what the [ __ ] is going
on why won't somebody help them she's
like somebody has to help them can you
believe this it was like what the [ __ ]
are you talking about and she's like
look at them they're if they're stuck in
the woods and this is happening and I'm
like you're watching a movie like that's
not real none of its real like it's a
fake footage movie you should go no
you're lying this is a snuff film and I
had to call John Pearson at 2:00 in the
morning and be like John do me a favor
can you tell Jennifer the [ __ ] Blair
Witch Project is completely fictional
and so I hand the phone ER can't do that
keV
yeah click and I hear her go like John
and then I can't hear him talk and she
goes who I won't anyone help them and
John talks and I can't hear that and
she's like are you sure this is
horrifying
she [ __ ] bought it hook line and
singer man like I wish I'd [ __ ]
believed in anything as much as she
believed in that movie in that night
holy the [ __ ]
but yeah alright did we get in front of
all the we go through all the news the
last story which is really we buried the
lead and should have led with I have
this this made me stop my work day at
9:00 was it 9:20 in the morning nine
nineteen I think he posed nine nineteen
am ray Fisher who played cyborg and
Justice League and for context very
often when stars are going out doing
press for movies they will never really
cop to any issues behind the scenes
because they're trained media training
happens and everybody's signing on board
and like we're all gonna be troopers
welcome [ __ ] so gotta sell the thing I
saw the thing so when somebody asked you
what was like making the movie it's like
ah man we were great hands and you know
I felt very comfortable and you know I
nothing but faith in our filmmakers and
you know I'm really glad that the movie
is where it it's like it's it's kind of
par for the course and you can start to
kind of read between the lines if you
read enough of these things if you
starts it a little bit me like maybe I
don't know
it's probably not the truth of it but we
you clearly were not all one happy cast
like for example Jim Carrey while
promoting Batman Forever wasn't out
there going like Tommy Lee Jones was
such a dick to me yeah like he was just
like oh my god it was great to work with
Tommy Lee yeah he's a legend he's a hero
so glad I finally got that experience
like it's it's the the lingua franca of
selling a movie is you just you you
swallow all the bad [ __ ] you only see
the good stuff true or not and so there
was a video clip of ray Fisher that was
shot I want to say comic-con I think it
was comic-con for Justice League after
Joss Whedon joined the Justice League
Zack Snyder of course we thought he took
time off but perhaps was unceremoniously
dumped or whatever and replaced with
Joss Whedon so at this point they had
done the reshoots and stuff and they
were at Comic Con to promote and Ray who
was sitting next to Jason Momoa right
says like it Joss is a great guy and Zak
picked a good person to come in and
finish up for him that's the quote right
and that that quote was embedded in in
the first of - ray Fisher tweets one
came a few days ago I gave a few days
ago and that that was the first shot
across the bow or a Fisher wrote of his
own comments in the video I'd like to
take a moment to forcefully retract
every bit of this statement which right
then and there is like wow oh that [ __ ]
what and you know and we should of
course point out that like he's he's
firmly in Zacks camp and has been for
like a long long time he was a released
the Snyder cut guy forever big believer
in Zack and in Zacks version of Justice
League as we saw from the trailers ray
and cyborg had a lot more screen time
yes so this past Wednesday two days
after that first tweet we would like to
force really retract everything he said
one more tweet out that said Whedon's
onset treatment of the cast and crew of
Justice League was gross abusive
unprofessional and completely
unacceptable he wrote he was enabled in
many ways by producers geoff johns and
john berg accountability greater than
entertainment
did he I mean wow it's like not that
it's noteworthy for a director to be
shitty to their cast because that you
know happens not to say all the time but
enough that it's not you know this weird
anomaly in Hollywood stories but it's it
rarely happens on a movie like this from
a star like that you know who clearly
doesn't either feel like he has anything
to lose right like he or feels that Joss
Whedon star is not of a sort of wattage
that he can help him or hurt him anymore
right but it's balls move it's just not
done
yes that's essentially it and believe me
when he says it's just not done we're
not disapproving in fact no still the t
would love all the candor that you could
fit yes but it is gobsmacking lee
shocking yes
to see it happen cuz so rarely does
somebody be like you know what sucked
that guy an [ __ ] yeah it was
let's go through the language of it okay
cuz the words are very specific as all
words are but like let's read where's
the it would go ahead break it down so
the first quote and and it was also like
it's not like it wasn't answering a
question he's just no it's just one of
those like he was nobody absolutely
nobody three years ago at comic-con like
why would you like to do that like I
mean pressing you anything I think it's
I think it probably is just like it's
waited on him like you know it from what
I understand like he's a theater kid
classical classically trained actor and
he's not like searching to be like movie
star he likes to act and he had a
character and a character arc something
he can invest in with a director
storyteller that he believed in and and
you know that's also his first director
more or less for feature and stuff and
Zack hand-picked him
and so you know when they make remake
justice league and like his characters
reduced to booyah which don't get me
wrong like it's a nice shout out to the
cartoon but like that wasn't in Zack
Snyder version I I can probably bet no
it seems like a Joss Whedon type thing
but anyway point band incredibly candid
and also like the timing is I mean the
timing is odd for anything seems
connected to the you know Snyder cut
release right but like we're now like a
month away from that big sort of
detonation that that was happening and I
was coming and everybody was like sort
of coming out with their support for
Zack it's probably something he's wanted
to say for a long time but didn't want
to [ __ ] you know jeopardize the
Snyder cut by Meghan be controversial
but now that it's a done deal he felt
like he could get it off his chest do
the language so so yeah he's like to
take a moment to forcefully retract
every bit of that statement so that was
the first tweet
second second tweet Whedon's onset
Whedon was misspelled by the way it's
not like yeah I mean but people's names
and sure tough to you know not everyone
can be Smith now winds onset treatment
of the cast and crew kiss stop onset
treatment of the cast and crew so that's
literally everybody it's literally
everybody yeah it's not like he was mean
to the actors but like a total champ
with the crew not like or vice versa
which it usually is it means that you
know in his eyes from soup to nuts
he was Joss was not a good dude to
anybody who worked on that moon keep
going what are the next words cast and
crew cast and crew of Justice League was
gross okay gross probably refers to
flash falling on at least story wise
flash falling on Wonder Woman like and
then quickly popping up and [ __ ]
apparently that was not in Zechs
version at all that came from Joss but
also I read something online recently it
was a Grace Randolph
- she said that when Whedon wanted to do
the sunset gal gadot said no I'm not
doing this and he used a body double
right
he was so ardent did that be in his
movie which is you know [ __ ] when
you're lead actress who is literally
coming off of Wonder Woman when one of
the most successful movies of all time
it's just like I don't want to do this
you know number one listen but number
two do you really go like alright well
I'll do with somebody else that's so
that could be I could be the gross part
of the gross and not just gross because
of what it is but just like you don't
you don't do that you know what I'm
saying this yeah alright so gross gross
abusive now probably not physically but
just beautifully via verbally barking at
people right but it could also be you
know maybe working longer than you might
need to like hey do these reshoots we
got to get them in we're gonna do
18-hour days like well dude do we have
to do 18-hour days like and I don't want
to say these lines and I don't want to
be belly-flopped on by Ezra Miller and I
don't like what's the next word
unprofessional I think I know what that
one is
and and I don't think that it's I'm not
casting shade like it's dirty stuff I
think I know what the unprofessional is
I'll tell you keep going and completely
unacceptable well that definitely I mean
right that's that's also a matter of
taste and opinion yeah it's the here's
what all those other words were um I was
in there we were in there nobody could
know except these cats and stuff but
like I remember remember on like when I
went to the skywalker set some people
had worked on solo and just both
versions of solo and both versions of
Justice League they're the special
effects guys said that there was like a
fair amount of trashing of the Zak's
version of the movie on set by Joss
again I know this is what a special
effects guy who worked on both versions
of movie told me but that he would kind
of like cut down dismiss and you know be
negative about Zacks version which he
had seen and all these people had made
together without him and stuff and so
the guy had said that it was kind of
uncomfortable on set because like the
people that he was talking to about not
liking that version of the movie we're
all people that had made that version of
the movie right so that I think is
probably the unprofessional thing like
you don't do that especially if you came
in to you know help out in a during a
bad moment in the directors life and
stuff but that's hearsay you know that
ain't [ __ ] in fact or news that's
just what somebody told me but it does
kind of line up with we're not this and
it also lines up with the second part of
the tweet which is he was enabled in
many ways by producers Jeff John and
Geoff Johns and John Berg because if the
studio as we've all heard you know and
everybody seems to have gone on the
record about saying the studio was
unhappy yeah with that version of it if
Joss is going to bad-mouth of that
version of it allegedly very allegedly
then that would be a kind of thing that
if the studio representatives are there
they would share that vision and that
version of what the movie was and so if
you know if the minders are also of the
same mind as you are then why wouldn't
you say these things out loud maybe
that's the enabling that that he's
talking about well and also just like
they I'm sure those somebody had to make
the decision to let's change course on
this movie mm-hm and I mean I didn't I
didn't know Jeff had that much power but
apparently yeah I mean I think he was he
was on set for much of the movie because
you know a lot of that is his baby now
from beginning to end was they like
let's he was he was handed the reins of
the DC Universe to help shape it and
mold it he was he was to be there Kevin
Feige was supposed to be there Kevin
Feige and this was supposed to be his
moment my crowning achievement was
getting us to Justice League
and he was apparently at the very least
you know involved in them decisions to
bring in another director and for the
director to be Joss Whedon and to give
him what he felt he needed to be able to
do that job which was you know a kind
hear from his studio executives who were
perhaps indulging his divisions on set
all of this is hearsay all this is
something yeah we were in there we're
not those please don't report it is
these guys said we're just saying what
others have said connecting dots some
maybe specious some might not but point
is I think look there ain't no dots to
connect on the fact that ray Fisher does
not like Joss Whedon no I think that's
what comes across loud and clear
totally didn't respect division didn't
respect how he worked didn't seem to
respect him at all and it sounds like he
didn't respect him because he felt
completely disrespected by Joss Whedon
there's a tweet that ray put out on June
6th which said I don't praise writer
Chris Terrio and Zack Snyder for simply
putting me in justice league I praised
them for empowering me a black man got
no film credits to his name with a sense
right he had no phone crystals this was
his first his first film with a seat at
the creative table and input on the
framing of the stones before there was
even a script the stones being his
father my so yeah so he was in but so
yeah he he watched his version of
Justice League like evaporate and turn
into the version of Justice League that
nobody liked like yeah it's not the one
that anybody was like yeah they did it
like it's not like you know Batman V
Superman has very ardent passionate
followers and stuff like that Justice
League I don't think has a bunch of
people defending it fighting for it no I
think they were hatched they were
defending they were defending Zach
rather than they were defending the film
yeah and the desire to see what they you
know attributed to be a damaged vision
for what that was like we want to see
what he wanted to do which I get and
raid you know is very much like hey they
invited me in and let
helped shape the lives of these two
characters because I'm sure you know sue
god bless them these guys on the other
Wow yeah I mean yeah man hats off to to
Rey for speaking his truth yeah and
maybe it's also like we seem to be in a
social moment at right now in a cultural
moment we're speaking one's truth and
and lightening that load that you might
have felt carrying for a long time
I'm not gonna say he's in vogue but is
the spirit is in the air yeah of airing
grievances and speaking truths and being
honest and start when when you're
looking at you know systemic racism both
in society and in Hollywood and how we
protect some people while we leave
others out in awhile to fend off the
wolves maybe that had something to do
with his decision to be like you know
what I'm tired of being silent about
this guy who was an [ __ ] who will go
on you know making stuff you know and
then to Josh's credit he's a very
talented writer he's written some things
that I love deeply you above a guy right
as a Buffy guy was an angel guy was a
Firefly guy like I you know I go deep on
Joss Whedon I'm not like disassociating
or [ __ ] on the guy while he's down
or whatever but I was never like a Buffy
guy or you and everyone that's totally
fine like and not because I'm like I
think he sucks there's just that was my
jam at all whatsoever but I know a lot
of people in this business writers
particularly in this business used Buffy
speak when they work on stuff people in
the writers room Emoto would talk about
like would use Buffy speak and stuff
like the terminology of The Big Bad is
directly out of Buffy like what's our
seasons big bad who's the big bad guy
that our guys like it's you know that
that writers room from Buffy
disseminated all throughout Hollywood as
did some of the storytelling lessons and
like odds are on one of your favorite
shows of all time somebody who worked on
Buffy was on it provide it was made in
mm and above like nobody a mash was in
[ __ ] the Buffy room right but like
you know it's what a deep cuts pull
you're like the only problem with Buffy
not enough master not enough Jamie Farr
I was always waiting for Jamie Farr
so yeah like it's it seems to be a
common issue that we had not having to
wrestle with every couple of years is
the trying to square it in your mind
loving the work of somebody who is not
entirely aboveboard you know it happens
in the comic book industry god knows
that we've you know been sort of
enduring that the battering of
revelations about people who have been
you know supposed the heroes of mind and
friends of mine who've been like oh man
that guy turns out he was a bit of an
[ __ ]
that's not cool wish that hadn't
happened and in Hollywood happens all
the time like how do you how do you have
growing up in the 70s and 80s and being
a Woody Allen fan still be a fan of
Woody Allen knowing full well here's the
kind of things that he did how do you
grow up as somebody who loved Miramax as
a studio having to reckon with the fact
that these movies were produced by a
monster I'll do you one better
how do you reckon with the fact that
your entire career is predicated on the
sale of a movie to that monster
yeah like as fans as creatives as what
we all have to find a way to I don't
know
morally shield ourselves from the sort
of damage that's caused by these people
and like I didn't do the things I was
not privy to the things I just made my
movies I just watched these movies and
loved them and then and love them to
death but divorcing the work from the
the artist seems to be now more than
ever a thing that we need to learn how
to do I think if we're gonna take
lessons from anybody apparently it's
very fresh sure just [ __ ] say what
you gotta say damn the torpedoes it was
breathtaking in its yeah sincerity and
it's to the pointedness yes and to the
I'm out of all [ __ ] to give very much
the any word from Joss Whedon Joss
Whedon to date has declined to comment
his Twitter feed has been particularly
quiet maybe that's because he's in work
mode
I don't need to raise my head above
water right now
my butt but it gave his Wonder Woman
script the chance to enter the
Twittersphere again and that of course
didn't go well no no no yeah man Wow
well that was the story of the week
right there that was the story of the
week because as we said at the top these
things are just not done now and when
they're done you're like oh and again
we're not saying these things are not
done and we disapprove
we're just saying like they don't don't
happen that's why it's so [ __ ]
noteworthy yeah like it's just like did
he I can say what we're just thing he
said yeah and especially from somebody
in Rae Fisher's position in the
Hollywood totem pole like it's Riskin
started yeah it's one thing for you know
[ __ ] you know Jack Nicholson to say
you know what Stanley Kubrick was a bit
of a dick like he worked it's really
hard but it's Nicholson you know and
like he could say whatever he wants like
that dude is impenetrable
yeah invulnerable he's never not going
to work
ray Fisher on the other hand like power
to him very brave you know it's it's a
bit like [ __ ] John boyega who was
deathly afraid of getting up environment
know how much of that is performative or
not but like that dude seemed
legitimately shook to get up in front of
you know thousands of British black
lives matters protesters and say there's
real problems that we have to address
and I don't give a [ __ ] if I don't ever
work anymore but I feel like I need to
speak what's on my mind and you know
consequences be damned I'm gonna speak
this truth Jordan Peele tweeted we got
you this barrage of like Jerry it's like
don't worry about it you'll work forever
you know but for a fissure like you know
he there is not that much he's all
upside there's not that much for him you
know to circle his wagons around but
he's like [ __ ] it I gotta say this thing
because I can't I can't swallow this lie
anymore good for him and that's bold so
good on you Ray Fischer good for you Ray
tell your truth that's all the news we
got that's all the news we got we got
questions we get some questions we got
some questions how's the audience
tonight JC let's
jaesi shot you JC monitors the the
comments and stuff how is everybody uh
we found out after the show last week
that like the thing what was the thing
remember you were like uh we were
talking about what we were like the
Michael Keaton Batman like who doesn't
like this idea at the end of the show JC
was like a lot of people hate that I was
like what and that's definitely a
generational thing
what was the controversy of the night
tonight if there was one just some
trolls in the chat nothing no no real
controversy no thankfully thank the Lord
all right what questions we got and
questions three Braden Goss Ghazi he
asked if Mel Brooks made a comic book
movie what property would you choose for
him can I go first you go for Howard the
Duck come on give the funny guy to the
funny guy man he gets two men plus
Howard was brilliant at social
commentary as was and is Mel Brooks so
as the Marvel character I'd give them
you
I think there's there'd be a temptation
to want to give him guardians of the
galaxy mm-hmm because I think that he
could have a ton of fun with that but I
think like Keith Giffen's West Coast
Avengers Oh excellent call would be
super fun excellent call yeah jail that
gif into mattis JLA run or that's good
man that's a funny books and you know
they told stories too but like those
it's a fun way but yeah that was fun I
think a good superhero book from him
would be a a lot of fun two good picks
let's get Mel Brooks on the line yeah no
how you doing
did I ever tell you that I saw Mel
Brooks's they had an AFI Lifetime
Achievement Award ceremony for him
looking like four or five years ago he
told a single best joke I've ever heard
was an improv and he gets up and the
whole thing he's giving us a little
speech after everybody [ __ ] sucks his
dick for the two hours that is all right
um who's got any questions out of here I
thought I'd one [ __ ] Q&A he's doing
crowd work in somebody's like boxes are
brave
and he goes depends haha I just like
[ __ ] it like that's pretty great 92
years old sharp his attack on his feet
it's pretty great that's pretty great
yeah yeah so now I got to burn that into
my head as a Mel Brooks joke or else
it's gonna wind up clever when I write
it marks gonna read and be like okay
about how to break this to you were
baked off your mind no wait which is
every night be more specific narrow down
all right question one done question two
all right question two is from Trent
Gibson good old Trent Gibson hey Trent
if you guys had to recast the main
Avengers with wrestlers who would you
pick oh my god oh I'm first enough and
wrestling to do this
yeah can all of them be Jimmy Superfly
Snuka I know this much Captain America
would be Chris Jericho just for the
irony of a Canadian is Captain America
plus he's my hero but yeah I don't go I
mean I guess like Andre the Giant as
Hulk
[Music]
yeah I'm not well-versed enough to to do
wrestling you Wow trying to find a Hulk
Hogan to put in there but this is like
if we got a political question I'd be
like oh so much with the tariffs Lincoln
oh wow this has never happened before
but it's like I think we have to yield
the floor to that question and as much
as we can't possibly answer it beyond
like he sailed my time suck my dick [ __ ]
you and hero this city deserves
truly all right so give us a different
question roll under a different one
Zebes argh Trent sorry give me Z B if
you could produce a sitcom for the 1970s
what would the premise be and who would
you cast you can use modern actors and
themes if you like
70 sitcom mm can it be a spinoff
yeah it could be you know ever you want
I let me see 70s maybe I do
Willona from good times you nice you
know what I'm saying cause she was like
always the breath of fresh air in every
episode of good times you know in a
better world just as good time spun off
of Maude because Florida worked for
Maude she was the maid in a better world
Willona would have had her own spin-off
sitcom from good time so I would make I
would choose that just cuz I watched a
lot of good times when I was a kid I'd
go for rule because that because then
you could bring penny into it as well oh
nice
yes I'm showing my good times geeky
mm-hmm good time geek is coming out yeah
I'm saying the Willona spit off from
good times that means ever you get every
week you did it get a different guest
from good time so JJ could be there one
week yeah Michael could be there one
week James senior could pop by because
they all live in the same building
mm-hmm
not very creative but I like my eye I
would watch that show
thank you because who do we cast it with
though and do we cast it well we cast it
with the actors who played Bologna for
doing it in the 70s if we're casting it
with a modern-day actress who's in
pretty little fires little fire door who
do I like Kerry Washington Mary
Washington there you go
modern and not the young and Kerry
Washington because you also liked her
remember there was a you all the actors
who played the young version of Kerry
Washington on that show she was [ __ ]
phenomenal maybe her she could pay a
penny what do you got I kind of want to
do like I want to do a sitcom about the
the first black sailor on a submarine
what do you call it I want to call it
like zero dark thirty but you can't call
going down down scope
one silent run deep we could play on
that yeah but like John Amos oh I'm in
as the black sailor on a all-white
submarine so it's like about integrating
the service a little bit and so you get
the social commentary and it's on a
submarine which I've never seen it come
on but I've seen their sub movies to
know that there's enough different kind
of sets and shares only ones to come I
could think of operation petticoat was a
movie they turned it into a sitcom at
one point Wow I believe it took place on
a bed to paint the put a sub sink if I
remember correctly of course they did I
would watch that watch the [ __ ] out of
that that'd be kind of fun in the grand
tradition of like you know sitcom set in
police precincts yeah which we'll see
less of I feel these days that's right
Barney Miller's and here's a kind of
dangerous job I mean what's it even mean
for like Brooklyn nine-nine yeah I had
suggested there's a lot like one person
went missing on Twitter I was like what
if just tomorrow they're in a post
office they just swim they do format
don't ever say anything about I was like
what do we do that but it's a firehouse
just like one day it's like hey
everybody
good to be back in the firehouse didn't
it talk about how much everyone loves
firemen yeah everybody's on board with
firemen know what they don't do shoot
black people believe I believe he's
right there kids yeah you don't even
have to go to Google to check that out I
don't carry guns no zero Pinocchio's
that is it much in fact right there all
right we got two sitcoms but we got two
sitcoms I love John Amos man James
senior one of my favorite sitcom
character favorite TV characters of all
time
he was so hostile to his kid to JJ he
was always ready to punch him out and
stuff do you remember when he died I do
I remember when remember there was some
through that episode and then remember
the episode where they they were like
neighbor came a neighbor lady in the
building was eating dog food and then
she came to like dinner and she brought
a
loaf and so like the joke was like they
were all didn't want to eat it because
it was like [ __ ] dog food and stuff
and they're like this is good pretending
not to eat it so and she caught wind of
it and she was hurt she was like yes I
have to eat dog food but I would never
do that to my friends like heartbreaking
noise I mean those sitcoms in the 70s
like taught people to be real I remember
I caught one because it still airs I'm
like you know some deep in the cable
[ __ ] landscape or whatever meet TV or
something there was an episode about
testing bias where like Michael was
taking some standardized tests and like
had done really poorly on it and then
you know it was a seven in the 70s and
so like Florida and James like truck
into the [ __ ] like to talk to the
superintendent and like well how can you
and ask him about things like you know
if I can if they haven't talked about
Hamlet yet they haven't talked about
like you know what it's like to buy a
house like all these questions you know
are the kinds of questions that he has
no life experience to answer man if you
ask him about these nine things he
totally knows it and if you look at his
testing for like empirical studies like
math this kids off the charts
history's off the charts but these like
interpretive questions he's always going
to fail it's an episode you could do
today absolutely I was shocked and also
and then I cuz it was like a satyr had
nothing better to do I haven't looked up
when did this episode air I'm having a
lot of good times season four like
episode 28 and good times was still the
number seven top ten show in the country
Wow with 28 million people watching
every week and it's like fair kids
anyone even Netflix can kill for twenty
eight million people to be watching the
playing at once a show that's making
like three million people is a [ __ ]
hit your average show you know your
average CW show gets less than a million
people a week watching and they stay on
the air forever now twenty eight million
people and that's number seven not even
that like that was super bolt I was at a
time where there was like three channels
your ops you weren't drowning in options
man so if you were on TV you were so
[ __ ] fast
this reality nonsense you give me famous
for being like [ __ ] well I guess you
have Charles Nelson Reilly yeah famous
for being on game shows that guy's but
I've had to get up to change the channel
so like once you were on Channel four
you were probably there all night yeah
and so like you're eight o'clock leadoff
was we got to get something to get them
to turn to two four or seven or the game
is up
do you know is we're fallen down a good
times rabbit hole but this all comes
from the Norman Lear universe so Norman
Lear adapts British TV show called king
of the house or whatever the [ __ ] it was
no the royal family maybe I forgot no
that was another show but it was a
British show that became all in the
family right all in the family spins off
the Jeffersons of course we all know
about Maude mm-hmm good times
Archie Bunker's place Gloria and there's
like two more very short-lived day at a
time did that also spin out one day at a
time is its Norman Lear but I don't
think there's a connection to any of the
episodes unless Bonnie Franklin's
character who showed up on something but
I think that was like a standard does
that come out of the Alice universe not
connected Alice wait Alice and what else
is in that universe Maude is Maude
Allison mater not connecting okay
they're all Norman Lear and Maude's
connected to Archie Bunker the I mean
call it the the bunker verse if you will
but Alice was standalone and based on a
Martin Scorsese movie Alice doesn't live
here that's right and so they you know
some people like Polly Holliday who
played Flo and Vic tayback who played
Mel they we lost everybody everyone's
like why are they talking about these
owners John a man's a legend I think he
showed up in in uncut gems that was it
Adam Sandler movie like at one point I
think it was that movie right
am I crazy no Johnny most sorry we
jumped around
was it the uncut gems he's in we're like
they in the hallway and he just opens
door and he's like that's Johnny most
it was like a unbelievably wonderful
cameo yeah there was some documentary
thing about Norman Lear and they
interviewed John Amos about it because
he gets killed
off-screen yeah like there was some
contractual dispute yeah John Amos
wanted more money and Norman Lee was
like well I'll just kill you was like
I'd like to see you try
and he does it yeah listen
it sucked for me but the dude does what
he says he's going to do I learned a
lesson yeah don't play chicken with
Norman Lear yes so Johnny Mohsen did Lee
but him leavin did lead to one of the
greatest episodes of all time
unbelievable weird Florida holds it
together throughout the entire day and
she's like I'm fine Michael I'm fine and
then at the end of the episode breaks
down [ __ ] it still gives me chills I'm
getting like emotional thing about she's
she's she's by herself in the kitchen
that's what brought him back like she
realized oh my god I'm like James is
gone oh my god somebody I mean I just I
you know I'm one level you like someone
should remain nobody she remake it is
exactly perfect as that [ __ ] thing is
I just hear if somebody shouldn't remake
it I wish they would make more well they
didn't like you know the normally alive
they do they played scripts and said
they've done some some good time stuff
but do you know how good times came to
be tell me so remember on story time
yeah here's of course seventies trivia
kids remember how the Jeffersons were
introduced on Archie on the family mhm
George and Weezy Jefferson moved into
the house in Queens the next summer and
then later on they moved on up to the
east side to a deluxe apartment in the
sky
what was their son's name Lionel so good
Lionel with their son there were two
Lionel's mmm fact Aaron that [ __ ] yes
but one of I think the first Lionel if I
remember correctly is his name in real
life is Michael Evans mmm-hmm
and the credits of good times creator of
the show with Norman Lear who I think he
might have been a creator it might be a
producer whatever is Michael Evans the
young boy the young son who was the
smart kid that we were talking about and
stuff like that not like JJ - rock star
and not Felmy his sister
the youngest Evans kid his name Michael
Evans so good times is the story of his
life his childhood [ __ ] beautiful
that's all so essentially he was on a
set with Norman Lear and telling stories
Norman Lear is like that's a [ __ ]
child
you know what I need that brain not to
be doing performing we're gonna find
another Lionel I'm not crazy you got to
come and write me a show good for you
Norman Lear yeah better for Michael
Evans for being on set man like me tell
you some story a great show a long we
didn't answer to a question that started
45 yeah responding to persons like I
didn't ask about this time I guarantee
you though some people right now are
going to look up good times to be like
is it as good as they say it is
phenomenal
I should have called it phenomenal times
I really kind of want like the ring tone
my ring tone to be as opposed to the far
easier dynomite that's too that's too
tricky if I let it get to the third damn
I'm just not picking up all right third
question take us home please let it be
about Norman Lear cuz we're on fire
tonight we're all here all the time oh
oh we're the we are the learjet tonight
Mel Brooks called
Rob Reiner played meatball yeah yeah
that's right he was me that he's
connected alright last question this is
from Lucas capo Massey and he wants to
know if you guys could pick an avatar
for a ready player one type virtual
world what would it be and what magic
item Oh somebody caught ready player one
on HBO this month am I allowed to pick
an existing IP yeah I didn't have to
so I could read where one just yeah
sucked everybody's IP so who would what
like when he's going on his date he like
tries on all these ideas and then when
he settled on his buckaroo banzai
ultimately and that's that's his that's
his I feel confident and I'm gonna kill
the world that wasn't a move II that is
in the movie yeah he plays buckaroo
banzai well before when he's going out
he's trying all these clothes and
[ __ ] Lena wafers the big weird like
hooking things like you to way that you
know you're going Banzai any collar
flipped up and the thin yeah who would I
be Oh who's my avatar [ __ ] Batman
it's the only world in which I could
possibly be Batman I would choose Batman
but then do you you don't act like do I
get to act like my avatar I mean you can
if you want it's do I have his skills is
what I'm saying or it might just dress
like that man I could do that in the
real world I think you just dressed like
Batman no like that I could do that now
I was doing it yes I want his power
though you could have like the magical
item that we're also saying the in-game
thing what is the magical item that
gives Batman his powers the death of his
parents just like it's it's the Bruce
Wayne credit card accepted all over the
world well I guess I should probably
pick somebody more magical and powerful
right
Oh [ __ ] Cthulhu Dan yeah nobody picks
Cthulhu they really don't
yeah I'd stop dreaming and wake the [ __ ]
up and everyone be like ah the terror of
my mind and I'd have a lot of room this
world it's a real estate cleaner
I feel nobody picks Cthulhu I'm picking
Cthulhu and what magic do I need I'm
[ __ ] Cthulhu that's fair in the house
of Riley anyway over to you picking an
avatar for ready player one for my
virtual world I am a hundred percent
gonna be Lando Calrissian which one
lassic or not the new coke but you know
the magic item is the [ __ ] cape which
is like you know plus a smiley cloak
it's just plus one against inhibitions
it's like a [ __ ] magic item
like anybody who sees that cape and you
just [ __ ] give a little furrow like
suddenly do it along he knows what he
needs you really belong with us among
the stars truly you truly belong with us
here in the clouds
hooked up that live big tough you better
get that gun you write your lines before
you because I'm gonna need it like
nobody will care because they will wave
the cloak and then and then yes what
have we here
nice that doesn't sound like I'm
practice that lie that one I practice
it's like if you practice that like you
practiced that duty speech you know that
goal whatever here what have we here
that's a good call man Lando Calrissian
yeah be cool you know or [ __ ] like
Michael Knight to most opposite things
in the world lately like did you the
ridicule in my life like what do you hi
just so that kid can be my magical item
do you just want a friend it's so cute
I want a talking car what's really truth
of Mark story is like I don't want to
hang out with any real people I just
want to call her that well talk to me
I'll have a friend will talk to me he's
also useful to get me to places were you
big Nightrider i was a huge megaman fan
did you you know how like we watch it
you'll pick it apart and be like it's
not real or but break it down did you do
that tonight right that's why you spend
your childhood gun that talking car is
possible anything's possible under
percent believe it yeah sure I would
like an ejector seat I would like the
capacity to go up on two wheels whenever
I want to not that I wouldn't need to
very often but I want to be able to want
the turbo boost and jump it over [ __ ] I
want him to give me like Hotel I want
basically want my phone to also tap into
my car and then do [ __ ] for me
suggesting to [ __ ]
such a weird concept dude in his car
yeah that's a superhero but I guess
that's what Batman it's dude mr. punch
people in the face we just lost the
internet though like Batman is a lot
more than a guy in a car you [ __ ]
idiot of course he is of course he is a
guy whose parents were killed
yeah Danny
that's is super trauma is his superpower
uh-huh what is the [ __ ] song in lego
movie where he's just like something
darkness dead parents and fellow big
babies like money helps that's it for
the questions did we answer him
we did we did we had avatars the only
thing we couldn't accomplish tonight was
fill the Avengers with wrestlers [ __ ]
know something we got to brush up on man
just in case somebody one day approaches
a dark alley puts a gun to our head and
be like replace all the Avengers with
wrestlers so give me like uh okay bang
bang bang bang bang there's a bunch of
people on the Internet when when I
tweeted about being on a virtual talk
show with sting they were disappointed
that it wasn't sting the wrestler that
it was in fact sting in the event
diagrams of interest I could see where
that's boss yeah man I was like no no no
it was the actual sting that was awesome
we were on Garry widows talk show animal
talk holy [ __ ] on Animal Crossing we
were literally talking to sting again I
didn't expect to be having conversation
with sting because I thought it was
going to be like oh you'll all be in the
green room together hanging out
virtually on discord and like yeah just
think I'll be there but I expected him
to be on mute and doing his other [ __ ]
and then somebody was just engaged he
was like talking and stuff and Mark
texted me he's like hitting all caps I
am talking to you did he's saying a real
tender just casual the way you would
sing Roxanne like if you were taking a
shower and [ __ ] yeah he just started
picking it off and one point he was just
like I don't know you're sitting there
going do we join in yeah I mean it's
tempting cuz I know the words but I like
listening to him sing to us it's really
he was so personable crazy yeah it was
really really [ __ ] cool it was later
over where he was obviously he was in
Italy and he had a glass of Campari and
soda very honest
[ __ ] stays feeling honest mark was able
to bring up [ __ ] dune - I did I
dropped the dive I dropped a fade route
really early in the conversation and
then sting didn't talk to me again I got
stay away from the dude guy yeah oh
you're one of those are you yeah that
was kind of magical thank you to Gary
Whitta for having us on the show it was
fun talk show with sting yes I do it's
[ __ ] dope man I wonder if people who
ever run into him in the real world like
hey man remember us know these two
rollin up hold up a card picture of the
cartoon avatar each other with you be
out of respect you know I'll be honest
with you yeah this was better than wash
and we got there it's a better [ __ ]
time bad watching a show whose title I
could never remember but you know what
it turns out this was pretty fun in a
world where covin spiking everywhere
across our country well everywhere not
in the world but in our country and
stuff thanks for hanging out with us
tonight
hopefully we took your mind off some
[ __ ] gave you a chuckle told you some
news we learned some things we did very
much it's pretty damn special I got a
bone up on my Houdini apparently it's my
homework yeah and I got a bone up of my
wrestlers it was I feel really like
vulnerable now yeah I'm gonna go on
Schmoe down soon are you yeah hopefully
they don't throw any wrestling questions
my way I'll be like screwed good luck my
friend I know it's gonna take some kind
of take something I realized it was go
down is that I have an enormous amount
of useless information but I that
useless information is not entirely vast
and so they they were asking [ __ ] you
didn't even know there's like oh I don't
know that it was like what was the name
of who were the bad guys in the Brad
Pitt film cool world I'm like holy [ __ ]
what serious yeah I'm like I have no
idea I know that there was a movie and I
know that Kim Basinger was in it too
it was a back she animal
yeah Wow I wasn't tell you that what was
the answer I don't remember like I
didn't commit don't need to know this
ever again but it's like those deep
pockets in the weirdest places and
knowing other people who compete and
take it seriously and do [ __ ]
research and homework and like this this
week I'm studying on westerns and
they'll watch every [ __ ] Western
because there might be a Western
category and this week I'm voting up on
my 80s teen sex comedy so go okay well
Wow look I'm happy to play but I'm not
that committee I'm not that committed to
anything including my wife child values
like that sounds like a lot of [ __ ]
words yeah I was like I I because I
cannot take it that seriously I I will
bow out of the ring and so you went in
and then you were like I'm out I went in
I did a singles match once and then they
had like a free-for-all that I did and
like I had a really good time but we
were like I'm ignorant but I knew it but
it became like I had a friend who didn't
want to pick up skiing at like 30 years
old cuz like I'm never gonna be good at
it like that's a thing you need to learn
when you're like 15 to 11 when like
you're fearless and you're invulnerable
and defensible at 30 I got too much to
lose I'm never gonna be good at this
it's like I only want to try looking
smart I've had that feeling since I was
a kid I'll never go good that's why I
might we're gonna try this is insane
I'll watch other people do this thing
oh yeah once once see how deeply
seriously people took it I was like I
can't I can't have step my way into this
you're scaring me off this [ __ ] bug
have a good time
it'll be great I'm gonna lose it sounds
like well if I had to gain oh my - weak
spots right now wrestling and cool world
I just admitted it on the air I would
like to see the the the we love things
of tapas you can choose like yes eight
out of ten of them will be Kevin Smith
movies and then one will be cool every
dollar man I know because I know a lot
about Kevin Smith do you have a good
time like tonight ladies and gentlemen
yes we sure did man we thank you for
joining us we thank JC for kicking
everybody out of the scum and villainy
cantinas we do our show men
heating up the co vid JC yeah
thanks to this man to my left without
whom there is no show mr. mark bernard
and ladies and gentlemen Thank You mr.
Smith and that concludes our contract
for this evening ladies and gentlemen
this has been fat man beyond I have been
Kevin Smith I have been mark Barnard and
tune in next time same fat time same fat
channel SModcast comp or youtube.com
slash Kevin Smith for the good of all
Cree